MR. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN RODA-GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ DALLEY. DODD DURAZO.
EGGMAN GLASER. GONZALEZ. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE MENJIVAR. MINH. NEWMAN
NGUYEN. NILO. OCHOA PADILLA.
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO. SATO.
SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN. UMBERG WAHAB. WIENER.
WILK. A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
SENATORS, IF WE COULD RETURN TO
OUR DESKS, WE'RE GOING TO GET
STARTED WITH OUR PRAYER AND THEN
A PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. WITH THE
MEMBERS AND THE GUESTS BEHIND
THE RAILING, PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LED THIS MORNING IN PRAYER BY
SENATOR LAIRD, AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. OH, GOD,
WHO WEEPS AT FRACTURED LIVES
INSPIRE US TO HEAL THE HURTING.
HELP US TO SEAL THE CRACKS
CREATED BY OUR COMPLICITY AND
FAILING TO LOVE. MAY OUR WORDS
AND ACTIONS SPEAK LOVE AND NOT
COMPLACENCY. MAY WE CHOOSE LOVE
WHEN FACED WITH MINDLESS HATE.
LOVE WHEN FACED WITH
RETALIATION. LOVE WHEN TEMPTED
BY DECEPTION. LOVE WHEN
ADDRESSING POVERTY AND OTHER
ISSUES OF OUR TIME. MAY WE
CHOOSE LOVE WHEN SPEAKING WITH
OUR NEIGHBORS. LOVE WHEN LURED
BY BAD CHOICES. LOVE WHEN
ELECTING LEADERS. MAY WE CHOOSE
LOVE WHEN FACING RACISM, SEXISM,
HETEROSEXISM, HOMOPHOBIA, OR
TRANSPHOBIA. IN ALL THE THINGS
WE DO, IN ALL THE WORDS WE SAY.
MAY WE ALWAYS CHOOSE LOVE AND
DEMONSTRATE OUR LOVE WITH
ACTION. AMEN. AMEN EVERYONE,
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR
WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE, WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
AS YOU CAN TELL, WE WILL BE
COMPETING WITH OUR FRIENDS IN
CONSTRUCTION. I ASK THAT IF WE
HAVE ANY CONVERSATIONS, WE COULD
TAKE THEM OFF THE FLOOR, AS WE
HAVE ABOUT 21 RESOLUTIONS TODAY
AND WE WANT TO GIVE OUR UTMOST
ATTENTION TO EACH PRESENTER AT
THIS TIME, WE WILL TAKE UP THE
FOLLOWING SENATE THIRD READING
ITEMS OUT OF ORDER. FILE ITEM 37
SR 106. AFTER ADOPTION OF THIS
RESOLUTION, WE WILL MOVE TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR FOR THE
SENATOR TO INTRODUCE THEIR GUEST
FROM THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK.
SENATOR NEWMAN WILL KICK US OFF.
HE IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE RESOLUTION
106 BY SENATOR NEWMAN. RELATIVE
TO INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
AWARENESS MONTH SEN. NEWMAN.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT SR 106, WHICH
DESIGNATES THE MONTH OF OCTOBER
AS INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
AWARENESS MONTH IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AS INNOCUOUS AS THE
TERM MAY SOUND, INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY RIGHTS ACTUALLY PLAY A
PIVOTAL ROLE IN FUELING THE
INNOVATION BASED ECONOMY THAT
HAS POWERED CALIFORNIA IN THE
DIGITAL AGE. INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY RIGHTS ENCOMPASS A WIDE
RANGE OF INTANGIBLE ASSETS,
INCLUDING PATENTS, TRADEMARKS,
COPYRIGHTS, AND OTHER PROTECTED
TRADE SECRETS, AND PROVIDE
CREATORS WITH THE LEGAL
PROTECTION AND JUST AS
IMPORTANTLY, THE MARKET
INCENTIVES THAT COMBINE TO
FOSTER A HEALTHY ECONOMY.
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT CREATING
AN ACCESSIBLE AND RIGOROUSLY
ENFORCED INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
SYSTEM CREATES JOBS, ATTRACTS
FOREIGN DIRECT INVESTMENT, AND
DRIVES THE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT INVESTMENTS THAT
YIELD NEW PRODUCTS, SERVICES AND
TECHNOLOGIES. NOWHERE HAS THIS
BEEN MORE IN EVIDENCE THAN IN
THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
FROM THE TECH STARTUPS OF
SILICON VALLEY TO THE CONTENT
CREATOR HOUSES OF THE LOS
ANGELES HILLS, TO THE BIOMEDICAL
RESEARCH HUBS IN MY OWN DISTRICT
OF ORANGE COUNTY, CALIFORNIA'S
CREATIVE TECHNOLOGY AND LIFE
SCIENCE INDUSTRIES HAVE THRIVED
ON THE CONSTANT PUSH FOR NEW
ARTISTIC AND TECHNOLOGICAL
FRONTIERS, FACILITATED BY A
ROBUST IP FRAMEWORK. BY RISING
AWARENESS THROUGH THIS
RESOLUTION ABOUT THE NATURE AND
VALUE OF INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
RIGHTS, BY FACILITATING ACCESS
TO LEGAL SUPPORT AND RESOURCES,
THIS LEGISLATURE IS REAFFIRMING
THE VALUE OF INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY, ESPECIALLY ITS VALUE
IN ENABLING CREATORS FROM
UNDER-RESOURCED AND HISTORICALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES TO
LEVERAGE THE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES THAT COME WITH
OWNERSHIP AND CONTROL OF THE
NEXT GREAT IDEAS. COLLEAGUES,
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CELEBRATING
CALIFORNIA'S CONTINUED AND
COMMITTED LEADERSHIP IN IP
EDUCATION AND PROTECTION BY
DESIGNATING OCTOBER AS
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY AWARENESS
MONTH, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. I VOTE THIS MORNING. THANK
YOU. SENATOR, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM? SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN, I RODA-GIL
ARCHULETA. ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLY I
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LEMON I MCGUIRE
I MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I
NGUYEN I NILO I OCHOA PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO SATO I
SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS I STERN
UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
I'LL GO ARCHULETA. I GROVE I
OKOBO RUBIO I STERN. AYES 37 NO.
ZERO. THE RESOLUTION PASSES
SENATOR NEWMAN WITH YOUR UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. MAYOR.
THANK YOU. WITH US ON THE FLOOR
THIS MORNING TO CELEBRATE OUR
VINCE WONG AND OTHER
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
MICHELSON CENTER FOR PUBLIC
POLICY AND THE CALIFORNIA
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY ALLIANCE,
TWO ORGANIZATIONS DEDICATED TO
PROMOTING IP EDUCATION IN OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AS A WAY OF
IMPROVING SOCIAL JUSTICE
OUTCOMES. ALSO JOINING US IN THE
GALLERY, THIS MORNING ARE
MEMBERS OF THE NEXT GENERATION
OF CREATORS AND INNOVATORS.
COLLEAGUES, PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THE BRIGHT STUDENTS
FROM CALISTOGA JOINT UNIFIED
DISTRICT IN NAPA COUNTY AND
SENATOR DODD'S DISTRICT.
STUDENTS FROM LA GRANDE UNION
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
MERCED COUNTY, AND SENATOR
CABALLERO'S DISTRICT AND MIRA
LOMA HIGH SCHOOL LOCATED RIGHT
HERE IN SACRAMENTO IN SENATOR
NIETO'S DISTRICT TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. PLEASE
GIVE THEM A WARM CALIFORNIA
STATE WELCOME. WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. YES, I
AM.
MOVING RIGHT ALONG UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. I OWE
YOU A BEER. YES. OKAY. WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH SOME REMARKS
FROM OUR PRO TEM AS HE'S GOING
TO PLAY PAY TRIBUTE TO OUR CCSD
POLICY FELLOWS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT, AND GOOD
MORNING, MEMBERS. TODAY THIS
BODY, THE SENATE RISES TO
RECOGNIZE OUR TREMENDOUS 2024
COHORT OF CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY POLICY.
FELLOWS THIS IS SUCH A VALUABLE
PARTNERSHIP THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE CCSD HAVE. TOGETHER,
THEY EMBED 15 INCREDIBLY
TALENTED PHD SCIENTISTS AND
ENGINEERS HERE IN THE CAPITOL,
AND THEY BECOME DIRECTLY
INVOLVED IN SHAPING PUBLIC
POLICY FOR THE GREATER GOOD OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS. THE
LEGISLATIVE SCIENCE FELLOWS HAVE
PROVIDED TREMENDOUS
CONTRIBUTIONS THIS YEAR BY
ANALYZING AND STAFFING NUMEROUS
BILLS, ENGAGING WITH RESIDENTS
IN EVERY CORNER OF THE STATE,
AND WORKING WITH MEMBERS TO HELP
TACKLE SOME OF THE TOUGHEST
ISSUES THAT THE GOLDEN STATE
FACES. SIMPLY PUT, THEY PROVIDE
A LEVEL OF KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERTISE THAT WE WOULD NEVER
TRULY UNDERSTAND. EVEN WHEN WE
GOOGLE. THE PROGRAM IS A
TREMENDOUS PIPELINE FOR FELLOWS
TO JUMPSTART THEIR CAREERS IN
PUBLIC SERVICE AND WITH MANY
FORMER SCIENCE FELLOWS NOW
SERVING IN VARIOUS FORMS OF
GOVERNMENT AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT LOCALLY HERE IN THE
STATE AND THE FEDS. ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR MAKING CALIFORNIA STRONGER.
THANK YOU FOR MAKING US SMARTER
AND MORE STRATEGIC. AND NOW IT
IS MY GREAT HONOR TO BE ABLE TO
TURN IT OVER TO THE SENATOR FROM
SANTA MONICA, AS WELL AS EZRA,
TO BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE HIS
SCIENCE FELLOW FROM THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK. WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE THREE SENATORS RECOGNIZING
THEIR FELLOWS, KICKING US OFF AS
SENATOR ALLEN. WELL, COLLEAGUES,
IT'S SUCH A GREAT HONOR TO
RECOGNIZE OUR SCIENCE FELLOW FOR
THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE THIS YEAR, DOCTOR
HOLLY RUDOLPH. I HAVE TO SAY,
THE SCIENCE FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM
IS SO FANTASTIC. IT BRINGS SUCH
TOP QUALITY PEOPLE INTO THIS
BUILDING FROM ALL OVER THE
WORLD, AND THEY COME IN WITH
SUCH CREDENTIALS AND SUCH
PASSION AND SUCH EXPERTISE. IT
IS THE CALIBER OF THE PEOPLE WHO
COME THROUGH THE PROGRAM IS
CONSISTENTLY HIGH AND DOCTOR
RUDDLE IS NO EXCEPTION TO THAT
RULE. HOLLY HAS BEEN FANTASTIC
WITH OUR EC TEAM THIS PAST YEAR.
SHE IS A SHE COMES TO US AS A
PHD FROM YALE AND SHE WORKED ON
GREEN CHEMISTRY AND WATER
QUALITY THERE. SHE DEFENDED HER
DISSERTATION ON DESIGNING NEW
SUSTAINABLE MATERIALS FOR
DRINKING WATER TREATMENT, AND
THEN JOINED THE SENATE
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM IMMEDIATELY
AFTER AND HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
US EVER SINCE. SHE HAS APPLIED
HER WORLD CLASS KNOWLEDGE TO
SOME VERY CONSEQUENTIAL
LEGISLATION. WE'VE HAD A REAL
EXPERT IN THE FIELD OF GREEN
CHEMISTRY AS THOSE BILLS HAVE
COME THROUGH OUR OUR COMMITTEE
ALSO WATER QUALITY. SHE'S
ANALYZED SOME OF THE NATION'S
MOST SIGNIFICANT BILLS
ADDRESSING HOUSEHOLD PRODUCT
SAFETY POLICIES ON BISPHENOLS,
PESTICIDES, ANTICOAGULANT
RODENTICIDES, PARAQUAT. THESE
ARE ALL ALL THINGS I COULDN'T
PRONOUNCE BEFORE I BECAME CHAIR.
PLASTIC BAGS, MICROPLASTICS,
RARE EARTH MINERALS. WE REALLY
COULDN'T HAVE MADE IT THROUGH
SOME OF THESE DIFFICULT
SCIENTIFIC QUESTIONS WITHOUT
HOLLY. SHE'S ALSO A REALLY GREAT
PERSON TO WORK WITH. SHE'S GOT
CHEERFUL OPTIMISM. SHE'S SHE'S
GOT YOU KNOW, A LOT OF
POSITIVITY. GREAT ENERGY AND TO
MATCH HER TALENT AND HER
INTELLECT. SO WE'RE GOING TO
MISS HER A GREAT DEAL. I THINK
SHE'S MOVING DOWN TO THE BAY
AREA SOON, SO BUT IT'S GOING TO
BE YOUR GAIN IN THE BAY AREA.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO REPRESENT
THE AREA, IT'S JUST BEEN A
REALLY INVALUABLE ASSET FOR EC
AND WE KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO CONTRIBUTE WHERE YOU
GO NEXT. SO CONGRATULATIONS TO
YOU. AND I JUST WANT TO ASK MY
COLLEAGUES TO EXPRESS AND JOIN
ME IN EXPRESSING OUR DEEP
APPRECIATION FOR DOCTOR HOLLY
RUDOLPH. BEFORE WE DO THAT, WE
HAVE A SENATOR WHO WOULD LIKE TO
ALSO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR
DAWLEY, THE VICE CHAIR. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS. I
ALSO TOO, JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR ALL THE INFORMATION FOR
ME. IT WAS VERY WONDERFUL. YOUR
EXPERTISE AND YOUR FRIENDSHIP, I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO DO IN THE
FUTURE, BUT THANKS FOR ADDING TO
THE EC COMMITTEE. IT'S BEEN VERY
VALUABLE OVER THE LAST SESSION.
SENATORS, NOW, IF YOU CAN JOIN
ME IN CELEBRATING DOCTOR RUDDLE.
AND. SENATOR CORTESE CONTINUES
OUR FELLOWS PRESENTATION FROM
THE LEADERS DESK. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. AND SENATORS, I
WANT TO RECOGNIZE DOCTOR
BENJAMIN O'BRIEN. HOKANSON, WHO
SERVED AS A SCIENCE FELLOW IN
THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE THIS YEAR. BEN AS WE
KNOW HIM, IS A NATIVE OF
WISCONSIN. HE RECEIVED A
BACHELOR OF ARTS IN BIOLOGY FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF WISCONSIN,
MADISON, AND A DOCTORATE FROM
THE MEDICAL COLLEGE OF WISCONSIN
IN CELLULAR BIOLOGY. PRETTY
SMART GUY. DURING HIS CAREER AS
A SCIENTIST, HE CONDUCTED
RESEARCH IN AREAS RANGING FROM
DRUG TREATMENTS FOR BREAST
CANCER TO STEM CELL MODELS FOR
NEUROLOGICAL BIRTH DEFECTS. BEN
BECAME INTERESTED IN
CONTRIBUTING TO SCIENTIFIC
EXPERTISE TO POLICY DEVELOPMENT
AND ENGAGE IN WORK THAT MORE
DIRECTLY BENEFITED PEOPLE. TO
BECOME A 2024 CCST SCIENCE
FELLOW, HE BEGAN THE YEAR
PIVOTING FROM WORKING ON BRAIN
INFECTIONS TO WORKING ON TRAIN
DIRECTIONS, AS HE HELPED
ORGANIZE AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON HIGH SPEED RAIL. HE
LEARNED EVEN MORE ABOUT RAIL BY
HAVING VIRTUAL COFFEE EVERY
FRIDAY WITH OUR LAUSANNE RAIL
CORRIDOR RESILIENCY SUBCOMMITTEE.
TO STAY UP TO DATE ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND PROVIDE
SUPPORT AS NEEDED. WHEN IT CAME
TIME TO ANALYZE BILLS, HE SHOWED
UP AND HE SHOWED HIS TEAM PLAYER
ATTITUDE BY STEPPING UP TO HELP
COVER A TEMPORARY ABSENCE ON THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND TAKE ON A
HEAVY BILL LOAD. WORKING ON OVER
30 BILLS AND THE COMMITTEE
OMNIBUS, BEN WORKED ON A DIVERSE
RANGE OF CRITICAL TRANSPORTATION
ISSUES, INCLUDING FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE, PASSENGER
FREIGHT AND HIGH SPEED RAIL,
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES, DRIVER'S
LICENSE AND AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE
DATA REPORTING. BEN SPENT MANY
HOURS RESEARCHING ISSUES,
MEETING WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
WORKING WITH STAFF IN ORDER TO
KEEP THE COMMITTEE INFORMED AND
TO NEGOTIATE WELL CRAFTED POLICY
TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION IS SAFE,
COMFORTABLE, CONVENIENT AND
ACCESSIBLE. HE'S A QUICK
LEARNER, A HARD WORKER, AND HAS
A CALM AND ENGAGING PRESENCE
THAT CONTRASTS WITH ALL THE
CLAMOR AND RUCKUS OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. HE'S
BEEN AN ASSET TO CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION POLICY AND A
WONDERFUL ADDITION TO OUR TEAM.
AND BEN'S TIME WITH THE SENATE
HAS BEEN MUCH MORE THAN JUST A
CAREER CHANGE. HE'S ALSO GOTTEN
MARRIED DURING THIS TIME, BECOME
A DOG DAD, AND I SAW HIM
DUTIFULLY WALKING HIS DOG JUST A
COUPLE OF DAYS AGO AND MOVED
TWICE. IT'S BEEN A BUSY AND
EVENTFUL TIME FOR HIM. WE'RE
VERY GLAD BEN DECIDED TO TRADE
IN WISCONSIN WINTERS FOR
CALIFORNIA SUMMERS, I SHOULD SAY
CALIFORNIA DREAMING AND LOOK
FORWARD TO HIS CONTINUED CAREER.
HOPEFULLY IN THE BUILDING
INFORMING GOOD POLICY FOR
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FROM ALL
OF US, BEN. PLEASE JOIN ME IN.
THANK YOU. DOCTOR O'BRIEN.
CLOSING OUT THIS PRESENTATION IS
GOING TO BE SENATOR SKINNER. YOU
MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, PLEASED TO HAVE YOU
JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING MAX
LATTA, WHO IS THE FELLOW SCIENCE
FELLOW FOR THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON HOUSING. MAX WAS ORIGINALLY
FROM NEW YORK. HE RECEIVED HIS
PHD AT UC SAN FRANCISCO IN
NEUROSCIENCE, STUDYING EMOTIONS
AND MEMORY. HE WAS COMPLETELY
ENTHUSIASTIC. I MEAN, JUMPING
FROM NEUROSCIENCE TO HOUSING,
WILLING TO TACKLE THORNY ISSUES,
ALWAYS SMILING WITH A GREAT
ATTITUDE AND THE FIRST TO
VOLUNTEER TO TAKE ON MORE WORK
OR FIND AN ANSWER TO A QUESTION
HE'S AN EXCELLENT CHEF AND BAKER
AND BROUGHT IN TREATS TO SHARE.
HE STAFFED THE COMMITTEES,
OMNIBUS BILL. HE ALSO ANALYZED
THE BILLS ON HOMELESSNESS,
PLANNING AND FUNDING, LAND USE,
MOBILE HOMES, BUILDING STANDARDS,
HOMEOWNERSHIP, HOUSING ELEMENTS,
IMPACT FEES AND SEQUA. AND HE
ALSO STAFFED MY VERY CHALLENGING
REDUCING UV RADIATION AND
VEHICLES, WHICH WAS THE PURPOSE
TO PROTECT DRIVERS FROM SKIN
CANCER. AND HE COMMITTED MANY
HOURS OF WORK WITH VERY COLORFUL
PERSONALITIES. MAX EAGERNESS TO
LEARN AND HIS TEAM PLAYER SPIRIT
WAS A LIFESAVER DURING A VERY
BUSY YEAR FOR THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE. AND LET'S THANK HIM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CONTRIBUTIONS.
NOW, RECOGNIZING THE REPUBLICAN
LEADER ON SOME CLOSING REMARKS
WITH THIS PRESENTATION. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. THANK YOU,
SENATORS, FOR SHARING YOUR
SCIENCE FELLOWS WITH US THIS
MORNING. AND PROPERLY GIVING
THEM ACCOLADES FOR THEIR HARD
WORK WITH THE SENATE THIS YEAR.
I'M ALWAYS AMAZED TO SEE PEOPLE
GO THROUGH ALL THE SCHOOLING IT
TAKES TO BECOME A PHD, AND THEN
COME HERE AND WORK IN THE
CAPITOL. AS I'VE SHARED SEVERAL
TIMES ON THIS FLOOR, I BARELY
GRADUATED FROM SAN DIEGO STATE.
SO AND IN MY IN MY FAMILY, I
HAVE SEVERAL COUSINS THAT HAVE
PHDS AND MDS, AND SOME OF THEM
BOTH. AND THAT JUST THAT GENE
SKIPPED MY BROTHER AND I. SO
WE'VE JUST BEEN, YOU KNOW,
GRINDING OUT LIFE EVER SINCE
GRADUATING FROM BOTH OF US FROM
COLLEGE. SO I'VE SEEN THE WORK
THAT IT TAKES TO BECOME A PHD.
THE DISCIPLINE, THE LATE NIGHTS,
THE HARD WORK. AND SO I AM VERY
IMPRESSED WITH THAT. WE ARE
BLESSED THAT THEY SHARED THEIR
BRILLIANCE WITH US. THIS YEAR
AND THEIR SCIENTIFIC EXPERIENCE
TO MAKE CALIFORNIA POLICY MORE
DATA BASED, I'M ENCOURAGED TO
SEE THE SUCCESS OF THIS PROGRAM
AND I KNOW THE FELLOWS INPUT HAS
BETTERED THE LIVES OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS, AND ESPECIALLY
THOSE OF US HERE IN THE SENATE.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH. AND I
PRAY BLESSINGS ON YOUR LIFE AS
YOU MOVE ON FORWARD FROM HERE
AND I'M SURE I SPEAK FOR ALL 40
SENATORS. IF THERE'S ANYTHING WE
CAN DO TO HELP YOUR FUTURE BE
BRIGHTER AND BETTER, PLEASE LET
US KNOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND TO ADD A FUN FACT TO YOUR
TRIVIA KNOWLEDGE, IT WAS SENATOR
PORTANTINO WHO AUTHORED THE
LEGISLATION THAT CREATED THE
SCIENCE FELLOWS PROGRAMS HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR PORTANTINO. CONTINUING
FOR UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. I'D LIKE TO NOW RECOGNIZE
SENATOR ATKINS FROM THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES I AM REALLY THRILLED
TO WELCOME TO THIS FLOOR A
WONDERFUL CIVIC LEADER IN SAN
DIEGO AND TO HONOR HIM. AND THAT
IS DOCTOR BOB BAUER WITH HIM.
THIS MORNING. YOU'LL YOU'LL SEE
SHORTLY IS HIS INCREDIBLE SPOUSE
WIFE, LINDA. DOCTOR BAUER IS
RETIRING FROM POINT LOMA
NAZARENE UNIVERSITY AFTER
SERVING AS PRESIDENT FOR 27
YEARS. IN FACT, TODAY IS HIS
LAST DAY, SO IT IS APPROPRIATE
THAT WE HONOR HIM TODAY AFTER 27
YEARS, DESPITE SPENDING MOST OF
HIS CAREER IN ACADEMIA, BOB'S
PATH TO COLLEGE WAS NOT
GUARANTEED. HE GREW UP IN RURAL
WESTERN PENNSYLVANIA WITH HIS
TWO SIBLINGS. THEY LIVED NEXT
DOOR TO HIS MATERNAL
GRANDPARENTS IN A SMALL HOUSE
WITH A SHARED OUTHOUSE. I'M SURE
YOU DIDN'T REALLY WANT ME TO
TELL THEM THAT, BUT IT SPEAKS TO
HIS HUMILITY AND HIS DEDICATION
IN THE LIFE HE CHOSE TO LEAD.
BUT IT WASN'T UNTIL HIS FAMILY
MOVED TO FLORIDA IN HIS TEENS
THAT HE WAS INTRODUCED TO ANYONE
WHO'D GONE TO COLLEGE, AND THAT
GOT HIM THINKING THAT PERHAPS
HE, TOO, COULD GET A DEGREE. BOB
WENT ON TO EARN A BACHELOR'S IN
SPEECH AND ENGLISH FROM TREVECCA
NAZARENE UNIVERSITY, A MASTER'S
IN COMMUNICATION FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CINCINNATI, AND A
PH.D. IN ORGANIZATIONAL AND
INTERPERSONAL COMMUNICATION FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF KANSAS. PRIOR
TO BEING ELECTED THE 14TH
PRESIDENT OF POINT LOMA NAZARENE
UNIVERSITY IN 1997, HE WAS
PRESIDENT OF A PUBLISHING
COMPANY AND HELD FACULTY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE POSITIONS AT TWO
OTHER UNIVERSITIES. AS PRESIDENT
AT POINT LOMA, HE WAS DEDICATED
TO ENSURING THE FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS LIKE HIMSELF, HAD THE
RESOURCES AND OPPORTUNITIES TO
ACHIEVE SUCCESS, A CAUSE CLOSE
TO MY HEART OF COURSE, AS A
FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENT
MYSELF, HE'S DEEPLY INVESTED NOT
JUST IN POINT LOMA NAZARENE
UNIVERSITY, BUT THE ENTIRE SAN
DIEGO REGION, WHICH IS WHY HE'S
BEEN HONORED THERE. HE SERVED AS
A BOARD MEMBER AND EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE MEMBER TO THE SAN
DIEGO ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION AND A DIRECTOR OF
THE SAN DIEGO REGIONAL CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE. HE SERVES ON THE
GENERAL BOARD AND THE
INTERNATIONAL BOARD OF EDUCATION
FOR THE INTERNATIONAL CHURCH OF
THE NAZARENE. AND I JUST WANT TO
ADD THAT PART OF THE WORK AT THE
UNIVERSITY, POINT LOMA NAZARENE,
HAS BEEN THE CONVENER FOR FOLKS
IN THE COUNTY. OUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY, NON-PROFITS, LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO REALLY COMBAT
SEXUAL TRAFFICKING, AND
SURVIVORS. AND THEY HAVE A
PRETTY REGULAR CONFERENCE THAT
CONVENES ALL OF THOSE IN THE
COUNTY. AND SO THAT COMMITMENT,
THAT DEDICATION, I APPRECIATE WE
SHOULD ALL APPRECIATE SO MUCH.
SAN DIEGO IS A BORDER COMMUNITY.
SO WE KNOW THAT THIS ISSUE IS A
BIG ISSUE FOR OUR COMMUNITY IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY. BOB, I WANT TO
THANK YOU OR DOCTOR BAUER, I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PASSION FOR EDUCATION, FOR YOUR
DECADES OF SERVICE TO POINT LOMA
NAZARENE UNIVERSITY. SO,
COLLEAGUES, WILL YOU PLEASE JOIN
ME IN HONORING DOCTOR BOB BAUER?
THANK YOU SO MUCH, DOCTOR.
WE'LL TAKE A GROUP PHOTO RIGHT
NOW. IF ANYONE'S INTERESTED.
WE'RE MOVING RIGHT ALONG. OUR
NEXT PRESENTATION IS BY SENATOR
CHIRLA BOGUE. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION STAFF AND
THEIR 13 COLLEGE INTERNS WHO ARE
IN SACRAMENTO TO WRAP UP THEIR
INTERNSHIP BY PARTICIPATING IN A
LEGISLATIVE DAY. THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
OFFERS COMPREHENSIVE INTERNSHIP
PROGRAMS DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
REAL WORLD EXPERIENCE AND
ACADEMIC CREDIT TO COLLEGE
STUDENTS IN VARIOUS FIELDS OF
STUDY. TODAY'S INTERNS COME FROM
CITIES ALL OVER THE COUNTY,
INCLUDING RIVERSIDE, CORONA,
HEMET, PARIS, MURRIETA, TEMECULA,
PALM SPRINGS, INDIO, COACHELLA.
AS WELL AS RANCHO CUCAMONGA IN
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY. THESE
STUDENTS REPRESENT. RIVERSIDE
CITY COLLEGE, COLLEGE OF THE
DESERT, CSU SAN BERNARDINO, CSU
SAN MARCOS, CSU FULLERTON,
CALIFORNIA BAPTIST UNIVERSITY,
LOYOLA MARYMOUNT, UC RIVERSIDE,
UC SAN DIEGO, UC SANTA BARBARA,
UCLA, AND UC IRVINE. PLEASE HELP
ME WELCOME THEM WITH A VERY,
VERY LOUD APPLAUSE. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US.
SENATOR GLAZER IS HERE TO
INTRODUCE HIS TWIN. SENATOR.
PLEASE PROCEED. MADAM PRESIDENT,
THANK YOU. AND MEMBERS, I HAVE A
GREAT HONOR TODAY, YOU KNOW, AS
MANY OF YOU MAY KNOW, MY FAMILY
AND I GREW UP HERE IN SACRAMENTO
AND JUST LAST NIGHT, WE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF GOING TO OUR
CHILDHOOD HOME TO, FOR SOME OF
US, SEEING IT FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN 50 YEARS. BUT I AM JOINED
TODAY BY MY OLDER SISTER. SHE
REMINDS ME OF THAT, DEBORAH LYNN
GLAZER AND MY TWIN BROTHER. NO,
NO, HE'S NOT MY TWIN. HE'S MY
YOUNGER BROTHER. HE'S GOT TO
ALWAYS REMEMBER THAT, GORDON
SCOTT GLAZER MEMBERS, PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THEM TO THE
SENATE. WELCOME TO THE GLAZER
FAMILY.
WE'LL BE GOING BACK TO BUSINESS
IN ABOUT 15 SECONDS.
AT THIS TIME, MEMBERS, WE WILL
TAKE UP THE FOLLOWING SENATE
THIRD READING ITEM OUT OF ORDER.
FILE ITEM 41 SR 107. AFTER
ADOPTION OF THE RESOLUTION, WE
WILL MOVE BACK TO PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR FOR THE AUTHOR TO
INTRODUCE THEIR GUESTS. SENATOR
MIN IS READY FROM THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE RESOLUTION 107 BY
SENATOR MIN. RELATIVE TO KOREAN
AMERICAN SENIOR DAY. SENATOR.
MIN. THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT,
AND MEMBERS IN KOREAN CULTURE,
WE HAVE A PROFOUND RESPECT FOR
OUR ELDERS, FOR SENIORS. SO IT
IS A PRIVILEGE FOR ME AS THE
ONLY KOREAN AMERICAN IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO PRESENT SR 107,
WHICH WOULD DESIGNATE OCTOBER
1ST, 2024 AS KOREAN AMERICAN
SENIOR DAY AND SERVE AS A
REMINDER ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
RESPECTING ELDERS WITHIN OUR
CULTURE. ACCORDING TO THE US
CENSUS, KOREAN AMERICANS
REPRESENT OVER 1.5 MILLION
RESIDENTS IN THE UNITED STATES.
THIS IS THE LARGEST KOREAN
DIASPORA OUTSIDE OF KOREA. 17.4%
OF THE KOREAN AMERICAN
POPULATION IN THE UNITED STATES
IS SENIORS. AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, WE HAVE THE LARGEST
KOREAN COMMUNITY WITH OVER
450,000 INDIVIDUALS. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE RECOGNIZE THE ROLE
THAT KOREAN AMERICAN SENIORS
HAVE PLAYED IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF CALIFORNIA, INCLUDING MY
PARENTS CELEBRATE THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS AND ACKNOWLEDGE
HOW THEY EDUCATE AND SUPPORT THE
KOREAN COMMUNITY. I ASK THAT YOU
JOIN ME IN CELEBRATING KOREAN
AMERICAN SENIORS DAY BY VOTING
AYE ON SR 107. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. COLLEAGUES, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN, I ALVARADO. GIL, I
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLY I
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LIMON I MCGUIRE
I MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I
NGUYEN I NILO I OCHOA I PADILLA
I PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SATO. SKINNER SERNA I SKINNER. I
SMALL. CUEVAS I STERN, I UMBERG,
I WAHAB, I WIENER. I WILK. I
AYES 40 NO. ZERO THE RESOLUTION
PASSES NOW TURNING BACK TO THE
SUSHI EATING CHAMPION FOR THE
INTRODUCTION OF HIS GUEST. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. TODAY
WE'RE JOINED ON THE FLOOR TO
HELP CELEBRATE KOREAN AMERICAN
SENIOR DAY I BY BRIAN KIM,
PRESIDENT OF THE KOREAN AMERICAN
SENIORS ASSOCIATION OF ORANGE
COUNTY, AS WELL AS MAYOR OF
FULLERTON, FRED JUNG AND IRVINE
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER TAMMY KIM.
PLEASE JOIN ME. THEY'VE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN UPLIFTING KOREAN
AMERICAN SENIORS IN CALIFORNIA.
I WANT TO THANK THEM EACH FOR
THEIR WORK AND SUPPORT IN OUR
COMMUNITY. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING OUR GUESTS. WELCOME TO
THE SPECIAL GUESTS. THANK YOU.
WITH OTHER LOOKS LIKE NOW IS THE
TIME TO JOIN IN THE GROUP PHOTO.
THANK YOU. SENATOR MIN EAGERLY
AWAITS HIS COLLEAGUES FOR THE
GROUP PHOTO.
15 SECONDS SENATORS, WE'RE GOING
TO GO BACK TO BUSINESS.
I'D LIKE TO NOW RECOGNIZE
SENATOR ALLEN FOR A SPECIAL
GUEST INTRODUCTION. SENATOR
ALLEN. WELL, MEMBERS, IT'S WITH
GREAT PLEASURE THAT I INTRODUCE
TO YOU A YOUNG MAN WHO MANY OF
YOU ALREADY KNOW. MY SON EZRA,
WHO IS HERE FIVE AND THREE
QUARTERS, HAD A WONDERFUL YEAR
OF TKE LAST YEAR THANKS TO THE
WORK OF THE STATE, AND HE'S
GOING TO BE STARTING
KINDERGARTEN NEXT WEEK ON
THURSDAY. SO HE'S HERE WITH US
DESIGNING HIS OWN FLAG. AND I
JUST WANT TO PERSONALLY THANK
ALL THE MEMBERS FOR COMING UP
AND SPENDING TIME WITH HIM,
SAYING HI TO HIM, HAVING
CHILDREN ON THE FLOOR IS A
WONDERFUL THING. AND JUST
APPRECIATE YOUR HOSPITALITY AND
WELCOMING. SO COME ON BIG
WELCOME TO EZRA. IT'S GREAT TO
HAVE YOU HERE, EZRA. IS IT?
SENATOR GROVE, YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. EZRA, WHERE IS YOUR
BABY SISTER? SHOULD I TELL HER
YOUR BABY SISTER? SHE'S NO
MOMMY. SHE'S WITH MOMMY. OKAY
THERE YOU GO. THROUGH THE CHAIR.
OF COURSE. YEAH. ALL RIGHT,
SENATORS, MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. WE'RE
MOVING ON NOW TO MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. NOW IS
THE TIME FOR ANY MEMBER WHO
WOULD LIKE TO RISE UNDER THIS
ITEM FOR AMENDMENT MOTION. THERE
ARE FLOOR AMENDMENTS AT THE
DESK. THEY WILL BE DEEMED
ADOPTED. SENATOR ASHBY, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AT THE. I'M SORRY. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. SORRY. AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR,
PLEASE PULL FILE ITEM. I
ACTUALLY DON'T KNOW THE FILE
ITEM. IT IS AB 2991 VALENCIA
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE
DESK HAS NOTED. THANK YOU,
SENATOR NGUYEN. SENATOR HURTADO.
MADAM PRESIDENT, AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR, PLEASE REMOVE
FILE ITEM A11 AB 892 BANES FROM
THE INACTIVE FILE. THE DESK IS
NOTED. SENATOR BECKER, I THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER 352 AB
3013 FROM CONSENT AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS. THE DESK HAS NOTED.
SENATOR WIENER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. THERE'S A RESOLUTION
AT THE DESK REQUESTING
PERMISSION TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE
61 FOR THE PURPOSE OF ALLOWING
THE BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE TO MEET AND REPORT THE
BILLS LISTED IN THE SENATE DAILY
FILE FOR AUGUST 26TH, 2024.
THESE REQUESTS HAVE BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
AND SENATOR MILO, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. ON BEHALF OF THE VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA WHO REQUIRED THAT
WE ADOPT A BUDGET TWO MONTHS
AGO, I OBJECT, SENATOR WIENER IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR
NINO IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ AND
RESOLVE THAT JOINT RULE 61 BE
DISPENSED WITH AS REQUESTED.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO. GIL NO.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY
NÓ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE. LIMON
MCGUIRE. AYE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. NGUYEN MIN. AYE. NGUYEN
NO. MILO NO. OKOBO. NO PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. AYE. SATO NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. NÓ.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
LIMON. AYE NEWMAN. AYES 39. NO.
THE MOTION CARRIES, PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE 29.1, SEE. THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON RULES. FILE
ITEM 318 AB 1038. MEMBERS,
WITHOUT OBJECTION, MEASURES
REPORTED FROM THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION DO PASS AS
AMENDED, WILL BE GIVING THEIR
SECOND READING. AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED AND RETURNED TO THE
SECOND READING UPON BEING
REPORTED. SEE NOTHING FURTHER
UNDER MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES, WE ARE NOW MOVING ON TO
THE CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE. WE HAVE ITEMS ONE THROUGH
15 UNDER SECOND READING FILE.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION 16. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2477 852, 21, 76, 22, 70,
23, 71, 18, 19, 18. SECOND
READING FILE WILL BE DEEMED
READ. WE ARE NOW ON SECOND AND
THIRD READING WHERE WE'RE GOING
TO BE DOING A MARATHON OF
RESOLUTIONS. WE HAVE ITEMS 35,
36, 38, 40, 42, 43, 44, 45, 46,
47, 48, 52 THROUGH 55. IF YOU
ARE AUTHORING A RESOLUTION, BE.
PLEASE BE PREPARED. WE'RE
STARTING OFF WITH FILE ITEM 35.
SENATOR ALLEN IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 161 BY
SENATOR ALLEN, RELATIVE TO THE
FIRST CONTINENTAL CONGRESS.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS LOOKING OVER
OUR OUR WONDERFUL CHAMBER IS OUR
FIRST PRESIDENT, GEORGE
WASHINGTON. AND IT'S A REMINDER
OF THE DRAMATIC EVENTS THAT LED
TO THE FOUNDING OF THE NATION
BACK IN, IN THE 1770S. WE'RE
ABOUT TO APPROACH THE 250TH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE FOUNDING OF
OUR NATION IN 2026. THERE ARE,
OF COURSE, SOME REALLY IMPORTANT
EVENTS THAT LED UP TO THAT. AND
THIS RESOLUTION CELEBRATES ONE
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT EVENT IN
THE HISTORY OF AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY. AND THAT WAS THE
CONVENING OF THE VERY FIRST
CONTINENTAL CONGRESS ON
SEPTEMBER 5TH, 1774, WHICH SET
IN MOTION THE DELIBERATIVE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESSES, THE
REPUBLIC THAT WE HAVE TODAY,
THAT WE EMBODY HERE IN OUR STATE
LEGISLATURE. SO THE IDEALS, THE
GRIT, THE DETERMINATION OF OUR
FOUNDING FATHERS AND MOTHERS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CELEBRATE HERE
WITH THIS RESOLUTION THAT
COMMEMORATES THE 250TH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE VERY FIRST
CONTINENTAL CONGRESS IN
PHILADELPHIA, SEPTEMBER FIFTH,
1774. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, SEEING
NO DISCUSSION, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE. AYE.
ALL GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY AYE. DODD AYE. DARAZO
AYE. EGGMAN GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE OR
DATTO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN. NEWMAN WAYNE.
AYE. MILO AYE. OKUBO AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO.
AYE SKINNER. AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBER WAHAB.
AYE WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD. AYE EGGMAN. AYE MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN UMBERG. AYES 38. NO.
ZERO. THE RESOLUTION PASSES
FIVE. ITEM 36. SENATOR PADILLA
IS PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE RESOLUTION 104 BY
SENATOR PADILLA RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA. MEXICO. ADVOCACY
DAY. SENATOR PADILLA. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I
RISE TO PRESENT SR 104 TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE 15TH ANNIVERSARY
OF CALIFORNIA, MEXICO ADVOCACY
DAY. OUR STATE, AS YOU KNOW,
SHARES OVER 140 MILES WITH
MEXICO. OUR CLOSE PROXIMITY AND
SHARED VALUES HAVE RESULTED IN
ONE OF THE STRONGEST ECONOMIC,
SOCIAL AND CULTURAL REGIONS IN
THE WORLD. AS AN ACKNOWLEDGMENT
OF THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
RELATIONSHIP, THE SENATE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, THROUGH THE
SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
CALIFORNIA, NEW MEXICO
COOPERATION AND DIALOG, THE
CONSULATE GENERAL OF MEXICO IN
SACRAMENTO AND THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HAS ANNUALLY
ORGANIZED CALIFORNIA, MEXICO
ADVOCACY DAY. LAST WEEK, ON
AUGUST SIXTH AND SEVENTH, WE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONVENE
STAKEHOLDERS TO CELEBRATE AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF THIS RELATIONSHIP.
AND IN PARTICULAR, THE HISTORIC
ELECTION OF DOCTOR CLAUDIA
SHEINBAUM, WHO WAS ELECTED AS
THE FIRST WOMAN PRESIDENT OF
MEXICO AND ALSO IN ALL OF NORTH
AMERICA. TO HONOR THIS MOMENT,
OUR DISCUSSION CENTERED ON
BUILDING AN AGENDA WITH A GENDER
PERSPECTIVE THROUGH BILATERAL
COOPERATION BETWEEN THE TWO
COUNTRIES. WE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HEAR SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS,
INCLUDING THE FIRST MEXICAN
MIGRANT TO HOLD A SEAT IN THE
MEXICAN SENATE, SENATOR ELECT
KATARINA RUIZ, WHO PROVIDED
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT POTENTIAL
AREAS OF COLLABORATION TO PURSUE
THIS AGENDA CENTERED AROUND THE
UNIQUE EXPERIENCES OF WOMEN. AS
CHAIR OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
THE CALIFORNIA, MEXICO
COOPERATION AND DIALOG, AND THE
ONLY MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE
REPRESENTING THE ENTIRETY OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEXICO BORDER. IT'S
MY HONOR TO FOSTER AN EVEN
STRONGER CALIFORNIA MEXICO
RELATIONSHIP FOR THE BETTERMENT
OF BOTH OUR NATIONS ALIKE.
MEMBERS, PLEASE JOIN ME IN
ACKNOWLEDGING 15 YEARS OF
CALIFORNIA MEXICO ADVOCACY DAY.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, THIS ITEM
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION? SEEING
NONE. AYES 38. NØ ZERO.
RESOLUTION PASSES. FILE ITEM 38.
SENATOR NGUYEN. IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION 108 BY SENATOR
NGUYEN. RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
PICKLE DAY. SENATOR NGUYEN THANK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I BEFORE I START, I
WANT TO ASK PERMISSION TO
REQUEST FOR UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
USE THE PROP. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES, TODAY, I
RISE TO TODAY TO PRESENT SR 108,
WHICH FORMALLY DECLARES AUGUST
EIGHTH AS CALIFORNIA PICKLE DAY.
PICKLED PICKLE BALL. PICKLE BALL
DAY. DID I SAY PICKLE? BOTH
EQUALLY IMPORTANT. AGREE. OKAY,
WE'LL START OVER. OKAY PICKLE
BALL. OKAY I'M GOING TO START
OVER. MADAM PRESIDENT, TODAY I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SR 108,
WHICH FORMALLY DECLARES AUGUST
8TH AS CALIFORNIA PICKLE BALL
DAY. PICKLEBALL IS A FUN, SOCIAL
AND SIMPLE GAME THAT COMBINES
ELEMENTS OF TENNIS, BADMINTON,
AND PING PONG INTO ONE AND CAN
BE PLAYED AT ANY AGE FROM
BEGINNER TO PROFESSIONAL LEVEL.
PICKLEBALL COMBINES ELEMENTS OF
WELL-KNOWN GAMES SUCH AS TENNIS
AND BATMAN, AND ADAPTS A STYLE
OF PLAY AND SOME OF THE RULES
INTO A GAME THAT HAS TAKEN
CALIFORNIA AND THE COUNTRY BY
STORM, ENJOYED BY THE YOUNG AND
THE YOUNG AT HEART. PICKLEBALL
FULFILLS THE INTENTION OF THE
INVENTORS BY CREATING A GAME
THAT THE WHOLE FAMILY CAN COME
TOGETHER AND ENJOY, REGARDLESS
OF AGE OR ABILITY. PICKLEBALL
WAS INVENTED IN 1965, IN
WASHINGTON BY JOE PRITCHARD, A
CONGRESSMAN FROM WASHINGTON, AND
BILL BELL, A SUCCESSFUL
BUSINESSMAN WHO SOUGHT TO PLAY
BATMAN ON AN OLD BADMINTON COURT
BUT COULD NOT FIND THE PROPER
EQUIPMENT. SINCE THEN,
PICKLEBALL HAS BEEN EXPLODING IN
GROWTH AND POPULARITY WITH
TOURNAMENTS PLAYED BY MILLIONS
RANGING FROM YOUNG TO OLD ALL
AROUND THE WORLD. THE US
PICKLEBALL ASSOCIATION HAS MORE
THAN 40,000 MEMBERS, AND IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT PICKLEBALL IS ONE
OF THE FASTEST GROWING SPORTS IN
THE UNITED STATES, AS
PARTICIPANTS REACH OVER
3,000,003.3 MILLION PEOPLE. WITH
THAT, COLLEAGUES, THIS IS WHAT I
CALL A SERIOUS PICKLEBALL PLAYER.
SO, MY ONE OF MY STAFF, JENNY,
IS A SERIOUS PICKLEBALL PLAYER,
AND I WOULDN'T COMPETE WITH HER.
BUT, YOU KNOW, PLEASE GO OUT AND
ENJOY. AND AGAIN, I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SENATOR. I
SEE NO MIKE'S RAISED. SENATORS,
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? I SEE NONE. AYES 38.
NÓ ZERO. RESOLUTION PASSES. WE
ARE NOW ON FILE ITEM 40. SENATOR
PORTANTINO. HE IS READY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION 103 BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO. RELATIVE TO ITALIAN
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH. SENATOR
PORTANTINO. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, I
PROUDLY RISE TO PRESENT SR 103,
WHICH DESIGNATES THE MONTH OF
OCTOBER AND EVERY OCTOBER 2023
AND THEREAFTER EVERY OCTOBER AS
ITALIAN AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH.
IT ALSO ENCOURAGES PUBLIC
SCHOOLS TO INCLUDE ITALIAN
AMERICAN IN ETHNIC STUDIES
COURSES, HIGHLIGHTING THEIR
ACHIEVEMENTS AND CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE CULTURE OF CALIFORNIA. SR
103 ENCOURAGES TAKING STEPS TO
PROMOTE THE INCLUSION OF ITALIAN
AMERICANS ROLE AND CONTRIBUTIONS
TO OUR CULTURE, HISTORY, AND
CALIFORNIA, AND IN THE U.S, AS
YOU KNOW, OR YOU MAY NOT KNOW
THAT THERE ARE 1.5 MILLION
ITALIAN AMERICANS RESIDING IN
CALIFORNIA, AND WE'RE AMONG THE
FIRST TO ARRIVE IN CALIFORNIA
DURING THE GOLD RUSH WERE THE
FIFTH LARGEST ETHNIC MINORITY IN
THE UNITED STATES. ITALIAN
AMERICANS HAVE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
IN SHAPING CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY,
CULTURE. PIONEERING PIONEERS
LIKE ANDREA SBARRO, WHO FOUNDED
ITALIAN SWISS WINE COMPANY IN
SONOMA COUNTY IN 1881, WERE
INSTRUMENTAL IN ESTABLISHING OUR
WINE INDUSTRY. AMADEO PIETRO
GIANNINI FOUNDED THE BANK OF
ITALY IN 1904, WHICH
REVOLUTIONIZED BANKING IN THE
UNITED STATES. OF COURSE, WE ALL
KNOW FAMOUS ITALIAN AMERICAN
ACTORS LIKE AL PACINO AND DANNY
DEVITO AND OTHERS WHO HAVE BEEN
PROUD ARTISTS IN OUR STATE, AND
WE ARE PROUD THAT THE FIRST
WOMAN TO BE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
IS AN ITALIAN AMERICAN, NANCY
PELOSI FROM CALIFORNIA. SO
DESPITE THESE SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS AND ALSO PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW THAT ITALIAN
AMERICANS WERE ACTUALLY TREATED
VERY HARSHLY DURING WORLD WAR
TWO, AND SOME WERE INTERNED AND
MANY PEOPLE. AND AS IT CAME UP
IN OUR ASSEMBLY OR SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE, SOME OF THE
MEMBERS DIDN'T KNOW THAT. SO
ITALIAN AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
PROUD CONTRIBUTORS TO OUR
CULTURE, AND MANY ITALIAN
AMERICANS HAVE SERVED IN THIS
AUGUST BODY, INCLUDING THREE WHO
ARE SERVING TODAY AND ALSO, WE
SHOULD GIVE PROPS TO SENATOR
CORTESE'S DAD, WHO IS A PROUD
ITALIAN AMERICAN LEGISLATOR AS
WELL, WHO PIONEERED MUCH OF OUR
STATE'S EFFORTS TO RECOGNIZE
ITALIAN AMERICANS. SO I'M PROUD
TO RISE TO SUPPORT THIS AND HOPE
YOU ALL DO AS WELL. SENATOR
CORTESE, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. I'M VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THE LEADERSHIP OF OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM BURBANK, NOT ONLY
AUTHORING BEING THE PRIMARY
AUTHOR OF THIS RESOLUTION, BUT
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP, HIS
STEADFAST LEADERSHIP IN THE
LEGISLATURE, MAKING SURE THAT
THE STORY, THE STORY OF AN
ITALIAN, AN ITALIAN, WE CALL IT
ASTORIA SEGRETA, THE STORY OF
ITALIAN AMERICANS, THE
INTERNMENT OF ITALIAN AMERICANS
DURING WORLD WAR TWO, AND THE
HARDSHIPS OVER THE DECADES THAT
ITALIAN AMERICANS FACED HERE AND
OVERCAME. HE'S MADE SURE THAT
THAT'S BEEN FRONT AND CENTER
WHEN NECESSARY. THE SENATOR FROM
BURBANK DID THAT IN COMMITTEE,
AND I APPRECIATED JUST EARLIER
THIS WEEK, THE CHAIR OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ALLOWING SOME
CONVERSATION AND BACKGROUND
ABOUT THOSE TOPICS AND ALL THE
TOPICS THAT YOU JUST HEARD. YES,
MY FATHER, FORMER ASSEMBLYMAN
DOMINIC CORTESE, WOULD BE VERY,
VERY PROUD TO HEAR ALL OF THIS
TODAY. AND HE WILL, BECAUSE HE
TURNS 92 NEXT MONTH AND HE WILL
GET A CHANCE TO REVIEW THE CLIP
FROM SENATE ED AND THIS. BUT
BACK IN THE DAY, THE ORIGINATION
OF THE FIRST ITALIAN AMERICAN
TASK FORCE IN CALIFORNIA, WHICH
STILL EXISTS TO THIS DAY, CAME
ABOUT AS A COOPERATION BETWEEN
THE GOVERNOR AND MY FATHER WHEN
HE WAS A LEGISLATOR. SO, AGAIN,
THANK YOU TO OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
BURBANK. AND HOPEFULLY I WILL BE
ABLE TO CARRY THE TORCH AND
FOLLOW IN YOUR FOOTSTEPS GOING
FORWARD. BUT WE APPRECIATE ALL
YOU'VE DONE AS WELL FOR THE
ITALIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU. SENATOR ANELLO.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. MY THE STORY OF
ITALIAN AMERICANS IN OUR COUNTRY
IS A CLASSIC AMERICAN STORY FROM
IMMIGRANT TO ASSIMILATED
CITIZENS. MY GRANDFATHER CAME
HERE AS A BABY AND IN THE EARLY
TIMES, IN THE LATE 19TH CENTURY
AND EARLY 20TH CENTURY AND AT
THE GOLD RUSH TIME, AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BURBANK ATTESTED,
ITALIANS WERE NOT EXACTLY
WELCOMED WITH OPEN ARMS IN THIS
COUNTRY, AND I'VE ALWAYS
SUSPECTED THAT IS WHY MY
GRANDFATHER EITHER ALLOWED OR
CAUSED OUR NAME TO BE
MISPRONOUNCED. IT IS NOT NELLO.
IT IS NELLO, AS MANY HERE DO
PRONOUNCE IT, BUT I THINK THAT'S
WHY HE ALLOWED IT TO BE
MISPRONOUNCED. BUT MANY ITALIAN
AMERICANS HAVE STILL MAINTAINED
CONNECTION TO THEIR THEIR NATIVE
CULTURE, THEIR NATIVE COUNTRY,
AND YET FULLY ASSIMILATED INTO
AMERICAN CULTURE. THE CLASSIC,
THE CLASSIC EXPERIENCE OF
AMERICANS COMING HERE AS, AS AS
IMMIGRANTS AND CONTRIBUTING
SIGNIFICANTLY TO THE FABRIC OF
OUR COUNTRY. AND I AM A COAUTHOR
OF THIS. AND PROUD TO BE SO. AND
I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BURBANK FOR ALLOWING ME TO DO SO
AND INTRODUCING THE BILL. THANK
YOU. SENATOR. SENATOR
PORTANTINO, YOU MAY CLOSE. YEAH.
REAL BRIEFLY, I MENTIONED THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY ITALIAN
AMERICANS WHO HAVE PROUDLY
SERVED AS LEGISLATORS. THERE'S
ALSO MANY ITALIAN AMERICANS WHO
PROUDLY SERVE AS STAFF IN THIS
BUILDING AS WELL. AND SO I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
APPRECIATED FOR THEIR COMMITMENT
TO OUR GREAT STATE. AND THEN
ALSO TO POINT OUT ONE LAST
THING. ITALIAN AMERICANS WERE
THE LARGEST ETHNIC GROUP TO
SERVE IN WORLD WAR TWO. AND SO
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE GREATEST
GENERATION, MORE ITALIAN
AMERICANS SERVED IN THE U.S.
ARMED FORCES THAN ANY OTHER
ETHNIC MINORITY IN OUR COUNTRY,
INCLUDING MY LATE FATHER. AND SO
I WANT TO GIVE PROPS TO ALL OF
THOSE ITALIAN AMERICANS WHO HAVE
SERVED IN OUR MILITARY AS WELL,
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR, AND
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE WHO
PROVIDED COMMENTS. THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL.
ANY OBJECTION? DO WE HAVE A NO
OBJECTION? AYES 38 NÓ ZERO.
RESOLUTION PASSES. SENATOR GROVE
IS READY FOR HER. ITEM FIVE,
ITEM 42. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE RESOLUTION 109 BY SENATOR
GROVE RELATIVE TO GOLD STAR
MOTHERS AND FAMILIES DAY.
SENATOR GROVE, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. TODAY, COLLEAGUES,
I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE SEPTEMBER
29TH AS GOLD STAR MOTHERS AND
FAMILIES DAY. GOLD STAR MOTHERS
AND FAMILIES DAY HONORS THE
PRACTICE OF MILITARY FAMILIES
HANGING A SERVICE FLAG,
DISPLAYING A BLUE STAR FOR EVERY
MEMBER OF THEIR FAMILY CURRENTLY
SERVING OUR COUNTRY, AND A GOLD
STAR COLLEAGUES FOR EVERY MEMBER
OF THEIR FAMILY WHO IS LOST
DURING MILITARY, LOST THEIR
LIVES DURING MILITARY SERVICE.
COMMEMORATING THE LAST SUNDAY OF
SEPTEMBER HAS BECOME FURTHER
DEMONSTRATION OF THE SUPPORT OF
OUR NATION'S COMMITMENT TO THE
FAMILIES AND OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS, ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT
GAVE THEIR ALL THE STRENGTH OF
THE UNITED STATES ARMED FORCES
IS BUILT UPON THESE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO SERVE IN UNIFORM, AS
WELL AS THE FAMILIES THAT
SUPPORT THEM. IT'S ESSENTIAL
THAT OUR STATE SUPPORTS THESE
FAMILIES NOT ONLY IN THE DAYS OF
THEIR LOSS, BUT MANY YEARS TO
COME. SR 109 COMMEMORATES
SEPTEMBER 20TH 9TH TO 2024 AS
GOLD STAR MOTHERS AND FAMILIES
DAY IN CALIFORNIA, AND
RECOGNIZES THE IMMENSE AND LONG
TERM IMPACT OF LOSING OF LOVED
ONE TO THE SERVICE OF OUR
COUNTRY. LOVED ONES LIKE
JONATHAN DIAZ'S FAMILY, THE
ROJAS FAMILY, THE FIGUEROA AND
JONES FAMILY, THE BORRO FAMILY,
THE BREEDEN FAMILY, THE MENDOZA
FAMILY, THE CODY PROSSER FAMILY,
THE KLAY PATRICK FARR FAMILY,
AND THE LANG FAMILY. THESE ARE
JUST A SMALL NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS FROM MY DISTRICT
THAT HANG A GOLD STAR ON THEIR
DOOR EVERY SEPTEMBER TO REMEMBER
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT LOST
THEIR LIFE. I THINK OF EACH OF
US IN OUR DISTRICTS. IF WE STOOD
UP AND NAMED EVERY GOLD STAR
FAMILY THAT REPRESENTS US IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, WE WOULD BE
HERE FOR HOURS. SO IN HONOR OF
THIS RESOLUTION, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE FOR THOSE
GOLD STAR FAMILIES AND MOMS THAT
ARE DEALING WITH THIS LOSS AND
TO RECOGNIZE THEIR SACRIFICE FOR
OUR COUNTRY. PLEASE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SR 109.
THANK YOU, SENATOR GROVE. I SEE
NO MIKE'S UP THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION? SENATOR
BLAKESBURG, YOU OBJECTION.
OBJECTING SEEING NO OBJECTION.
AYES 38. NÓ ZERO. RESOLUTION
PASSES. MOVING ON TO ITEM 43.
SENATOR BLAKESBURG IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION 111 BY SENATOR
BLAKESLEE. RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES MONTH.
SENATOR BIXBY, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. TODAY I RISE TO
INTRODUCE SR 111 RECOGNIZING
AUGUST AS LIFE SCIENCES MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS PARTICULARLY
APPROPRIATE RECOGNITION TODAY,
FOLLOWING THE HONORING OF OUR
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY FELLOWS.
OUR STATE HAS LONG BEEN A GLOBAL
LEADER IN THE LIFE SCIENCES
INDUSTRY, AND IT'S TIME WE
RECOGNIZE THE IMMENSE
CONTRIBUTIONS THIS SECTOR MAKES
TO OUR ECONOMY, HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM AND SCIENTIFIC
ADVANCEMENT. THE LIFE SCIENCES
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA IS
NOTHING SHORT OF REMARKABLE.
THROUGHOUT THE LAST FEW DECADES,
THIS INDUSTRY HAS MADE
GROUNDBREAKING DISCOVERIES. IT'S
HOW WE KNOW WHAT THE STRUCTURE
OF DNA IS. THE LIFE SCIENCES
INDUSTRY IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
HUMAN GENOME PROJECT
SUCCESSFULLY FIGHTING COVID 19
LIFE SAVING VACCINES, MEDICINES,
MEDICINES, THERAPIES AND SO MUCH
MORE. THE BEST THING IS THAT
CALIFORNIA IS THE LEADER.
COMPANIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA ARE
LEADING IN BIOTECHNOLOGY,
PHARMACEUTICALS, MEDICAL
DEVICES, ONCOLOGY, NEUROSCIENCE,
RARE DISEASES AND CUTTING EDGE
THERAPIES. IN 2023 ALONE, THIS
SECTOR PAID AN ESTIMATED $57
BILLION IN WAGES TO EMPLOYEES
ACROSS OUR STATE. WE'RE HOME TO
OVER 18,000 LIFE SCIENCES
ESTABLISHMENTS THAT PROVIDE HIGH
QUALITY JOBS AND DRIVE
INNOVATION THAT BENEFITS NOT
JUST CALIFORNIA, BUT THE ENTIRE
WORLD. THE LIFE SCIENCES
INDUSTRY DIRECTLY EMPLOYS ALMOST
HALF A MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
THESE AREN'T JUST JOBS, THEY'RE
IMPORTANT CAREERS WITH
SIGNIFICANT EARNING POTENTIAL.
IN 2023, OUR STATE'S BIOTECHS
RAISED $5 BILLION THROUGH 157
VENTURE CAPITAL DEALS, UP FROM
$4 BILLION JUST ONE YEAR AGO. IN
2022. THIS INCREASE IN
INVESTMENT EVEN DURING
CHALLENGING ECONOMIC TIMES,
SPEAKS VOLUMES ABOUT THE
STRENGTH AND POTENTIAL OF OUR
LIFE SCIENCES SECTOR. OUR
STATE'S LIFE SCIENCES ECOSYSTEM
IS DIVERSE AND ROBUST, WITH
SEVERAL REGIONS CONTRIBUTING
SIGNIFICANTLY. IN ADDITION TO
SAN DIEGO COUNTY, ORANGE COUNTY,
THE BAY AREA AND LOS ANGELES
ALSO CONTRIBUTE SIGNIFICANTLY TO
OUR LIFE SCIENCES LEADERSHIP,
AND I KNOW MY COLLEAGUES FROM
THOSE REGIONS ARE PROUD OF THEIR
INDUSTRIES AND THEIR DISTRICTS
AS WELL. BY RECOGNIZING AUGUST
AS LIFE SCIENCES MONTH, WE
CELEBRATE THE INCREDIBLE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THIS INDUSTRY
TO OUR STATE'S ECONOMY, HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM, AND GLOBAL
SCIENTIFIC LEADERSHIP. WE THANK
THE RESEARCHERS, ENTREPRENEURS,
AND WORKERS WHO DRIVE INNOVATION
AND IMPROVE LIVES EVERY DAY. I
ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO SUPPORT
THIS RESOLUTION AND JOIN ME IN
CELEBRATING LIFE SCIENCES MONTH
THIS AUGUST. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR SENO. DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE, THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. I SEE
NO OBJECTION. AYES 38. NO ZERO.
THE RESOLUTION PASSES. MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM 44. SENATOR RUBIO
IS PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE RESOLUTION 113 BY
SENATOR RUBIO RELATIVE TO
LATINA, EQUAL PAY DAY. SENATOR
RUBIO, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE, TODAY I RISE TO
PROUDLY PRESENT A WOMEN'S CAUCUS
RESOLUTION SR 113, WHICH
PROCLAIMS OCTOBER 3RD, 2024 AS
LATINA EQUAL PAY DAY. CALIFORNIA
HAS A HIGH, THE LARGEST HISPANIC
POPULATION AND THE HIGHEST
CONCENTRATION OF LATINAS OF ANY
STATE. IN 2022. LATINAS COMPRISE
20% OF TOTAL POPULATION, ALMOST
7.8 MILLION, AND 40% OF ALL
WOMEN. YET ACCORDING TO THE 2024
ECONOMIC STATUS OF LATINAS AND
CALIFORNIA'S REPORT, LATINAS
WITH ANY EARNINGS IN CALIFORNIA
IN 2022 WERE ONLY PAID $0.42 FOR
EVERY DOLLAR COMPARED TO THEIR
MALE COUNTERPARTS MORE THAN 50
YEARS AGO, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PASSED THE EQUAL PAY
ACT IN ORDER TO ADDRESS GENDER,
WAGE DISCRIMINATION.
NEVERTHELESS WOMEN, ESPECIALLY
WOMEN OF COLOR, CONTINUE TO
SUFFER THE INEQUITIES OF PAY.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
WOMEN'S LAW CENTER, CALIFORNIA'S
LATINO WAGE GAP IS RANKED THE
HIGHEST AT NUMBER 50 IN THE
COUNTRY, AND THAT IS
UNACCEPTABLE. THESE INEQUITIES
AFFECT FUTURE OPPORTUNITIES TO
SAVE FOR RETIREMENT AND OBTAIN
FINANCIAL SECURITY FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. IN ADDITION, THEIR
OPPORTUNITY FOR GENERATIONAL
WEALTH IS SUPPRESSED AND MAY NOT
BE ACHIEVED. LET'S WORK TO
ELIMINATE THIS WAGE GAP AND
START GIVING LATINA WOMEN THE
RESPECT AND COMPENSATION THEY
EARNED AND DESERVE. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR RUBIO. I SEE NO MICS UP
FOR DISCUSSION. THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION? ALSO,
SEEING NONE. AYES 38 NÓ ZERO
RESOLUTION PASSES. WE ARE NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 45. MR.
PRO TEM IS READY. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE RESOLUTION
114 BY SENATOR MCGUIRE, RELATIVE
TO PRESIDENT JOSEPH BIDEN. MR.
PRO TEM, THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS,
TODAY, I RISE WITH GREAT RESPECT
AND IMMENSE GRATITUDE IN HONOR
OF OUR NATION'S 46TH PRESIDENT,
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN. PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS SERVED THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC WITH GRACE, GRIT AND
DETERMINATION FOR GENERATIONS,
WHICH IS WHY WE ADVANCE THIS
RESOLUTION TODAY WITH HIS
DECISION TO BE ABLE TO SEEK
RETIREMENT AND WE CELEBRATE HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS FOR THE GREATER
PART OF A HALF CENTURY. HE WAS A
FORCE TO BE RECKONED WITH IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE, A VOICE
FOR WORKING FAMILIES, THE MOST
VULNERABLE. AND HE AUTHORED
LANDMARK LEGISLATION LIKE THE
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN ACT. AS
VICE PRESIDENT, HE FOUGHT TO
STRENGTHEN THE MIDDLE CLASS,
HELP AMERICA RECOVER AND BOUNCE
BACK FROM THE WORST RECESSION
SINCE THE GREAT DEPRESSION. HE
LED EFFORTS TO BE ABLE TO
PREVENT, DIAGNOSE AND TREAT
CANCER AFTER TAKING OFFICE AS
PRESIDENT DURING THE HEIGHT OF
COVID 19, PRESIDENT BIDEN
ACCOMPLISHED MORE LEGISLATIVELY,
MORE LEGISLATIVELY IN HIS FIRST
TWO YEARS IN OFFICE THAN LYNDON
B JOHNSON, RESCUING THE ECONOMY
AND CHANGING THE COURSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. HE SIGNED THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE RELIEF TO HARD WORKING
AMERICANS, FEELING THE IMPACTS
THE DEEP IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC. HE SIGNED THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES AND
SUPPORT RENEWABLE ENERGY. AND
LET'S NOT FORGET THE CHIPS ACT.
STAND UP TO CHINA AND BRING
AMERICAN MANUFACTURING JOBS BACK
HOME. AND THROUGH THE BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE LAW, EVERY DAY IS
INFRASTRUCTURE WEEK. PRESIDENT
BIDEN MADE THE LARGEST
INVESTMENT IN OUR NATION'S
INFRASTRUCTURE IN NEARLY A
CENTURY, INJECTING OVER $1
TRILLION IN PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS, FIXING BRIDGES AND
ROADS AND HIGHWAYS. $41 BILLION
ALONE COMING INTO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO HELP MODERNIZE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND BIG
COMMUNITIES AND SMALL IN EVERY
CORNER OF THIS GREAT STATE. HE'S
LOWERED PRESCRIPTION DRUG
PRICES. HE'S PROVIDED DEBT
RELIEF TO 40 MILLION STUDENTS.
AND WITH HIS LEADERSHIP AND
SUPPORT FOR UKRAINE, HE HAS
STOOD UP TO PUTIN SAFEGUARDING
DEMOCRACY WORLDWIDE AND
BOLSTERING OUR ALLIES AND OUR
NATO MEMBERSHIP. IT'S A BIT OF
AN EMOTIONAL MOMENT, I THINK,
FOR ALL OF US. FOR FIVE DECADES,
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS DEDICATED
HIS LIFE TO PUBLIC SERVICE,
UPLIFTING AMERICANS. NO MATTER
WHAT YOUR PARTY AFFILIATION MAY
BE IN EVERY CORNER OF THE UNITED
STATES. AND LOOK, WE LIVE IN
HYPER PARTIZAN TIMES, AND I KNOW
NOT EVERY PERSON IN THIS ROOM
MAY FEEL THE SAME THE WAY I DO
ABOUT OUR PRESIDENT, BUT I GOT
TO SAY THIS PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
LIFETIME TRACK RECORD IS PROOF.
WHEN WE ALL WORK TOGETHER,
AMERICA IS STRONGER. PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS FOUGHT LIKE HELL AND
BUILT A BETTER AMERICA BECAUSE
OF IT. HIS IMPACT AND LEGACY OF
SERVICE IS WEAVED INTO EVERY
FABRIC OF OUR NATION. AND I'M
TREMENDOUSLY GRATEFUL. AND I
KNOW SO MANY OF US ARE FOR
EVERYTHING THAT HE HAS
CONTRIBUTED AND RESPECTFULLY
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SR 114.
THANK YOU, MR. PRO TEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE. MIKE'S UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I'LL
GO. ARCHULETA HI, ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE
DALLY. DODD AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO. AYE
JONES. LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN. AYE.
MAGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN NGUYEN. NHIÀU OKOBO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE RUBIO. AYE SEYARTO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE
STERN. AYE. UMBERG WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. AYE
ALVARADO. BECKER. AYE DALI.
GROVE JONES. NEWMAN NGUYEN.
YELLOW OKOBO. SEYARTO UMBERG.
WILK NØ. AYE HE'S 29. ONE NOES.
RESOLUTION PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 46. SENATOR GROVE,
BACK UP. SHE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION 115 BY SENATOR GROVE,
RELATIVE TO FOOD AND AGRICULTURE.
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT SR 115, WHICH
DESIGNATES OCTOBER AS CALIFORNIA
INTERMEDIATE CROP MONTH. AN
INTERMEDIATE CROP IS A NON-FOOD
CROP THAT IS PLANTED IN FARMLAND
BETWEEN THEIR MAIN CROP
ROTATIONS. SOME CROPS, LIKE
CAMELINA SATIVA. IT'S A USED FOR
RENEWABLE BIOMASS AND PROVIDES
AN IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY FOR
FARMERS TO GENERATE ADDITIONAL
INCOME WITHOUT DISPLACING THEIR
ORIGINAL FOOD CROPS. BESIDES
CREATING A POTENTIAL FOR BIOMASS
ENERGY, INTERMEDIATE CROPS ALSO
PRODUCE PROVIDE AN ADVANTAGE OF
REDUCING SOIL EROSION AND
NUTRIENT LOSS BY INCREASING THE
PLANTED ACREAGE OF INTERMEDIATE
CROPS, CALIFORNIA CAN FURTHER
STRENGTHEN DOMESTIC ENERGY
PRODUCTION WHILE BOLSTERING
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND ECONOMIES.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING SHR
115 AND SUPPORTING THE
PRODUCTION OF THESE IMPORTANT
CROPS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR, ANY
MIKE'S UP FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? I SEE NONE THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION? SEEING NONE
AS WELL. AYES 38. NØ ZERO.
RESOLUTION PASSES FIVE. ITEM 47.
SENATOR CORTESE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION 116 BY SENATOR
CORTESE. SENATOR RELATIVE TO
TAIWAN. SENATOR CORTESE, THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT, AND
MEMBERS, SHR 116 CELEBRATES THE
40TH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAIWAN SISTER
STATEHOOD RELATIONSHIP. THE
PURPOSE OF THE SISTER STATEHOOD
IS TO FORM GREATER CONNECTION,
FRIENDSHIP AND UNDERSTANDING
BETWEEN NATIONS. SINCE OUR
SISTER STATEHOOD BOND WAS
ESTABLISHED WITH TAIWAN IN 1984,
TAIWAN ITSELF HAS ENJOYED
EXTENSIVE CLOSE AND FRIENDLY
RELATIONS WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND TAIWAN,
AND THE AREAS OF TRADE, SCIENCE,
TECHNOLOGY, EDUCATION, TOURISM,
AND CULTURE HAVE STRENGTHENED
CONSIDERABLY OVER THAT TIME.
OVER THE YEARS, TAIWANESE
COMMUNITIES HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT, INCLUDING IN MY OWN
DISTRICT IN THE BAY AREA. TAIWAN
IS NOW CALIFORNIA'S THIRD
LARGEST TRADING PARTNER, THIRD
LARGEST. I WANT TO REPEAT THAT
WITH A BILATERAL TRADE VOLUME OF
$38 BILLION IN CONTRIBUTING MORE
THAN 120,000 JOBS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE PEOPLE OF TAIWAN, LIKE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
UNITED STATES, HAVE OVERCOME
GREAT ADVERSITY AND HAVE BUILT A
SUCCESSFUL, PROSPEROUS AND FREE
ECONOMY. TAIWAN. THE UNITED
STATES SHARE COMMON IDEALS FOR A
HEALTHY, PEACEFUL, AND
DEMOCRATIC 21ST CENTURY, AND
BOTH COUNTRIES CONTRIBUTE
MEANINGFULLY. EXCUSE ME BOTH
ENTITIES CONTRIBUTE MEANINGFULLY
ON AN INTERNATIONAL LEVEL TO
FOSTER THESE IDEALS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
VOTE ON SR 116 TO CELEBRATE 40
YEARS OF CALIFORNIA, TAIWAN
SISTER STATEHOOD. THANK YOU. AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SENATOR YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I
RISE ON BEHALF OF THE AAPI
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION. TAIWAN IS AN
EXAMPLE OF WHAT A FREEDOM AND
DEMOCRACY CAN BRING TO A VIBRANT
ECONOMY. WE SHOULD STAND STRONG
WITH OUR ALLIES OVER THERE. AND
I URGE AND I VOTE, SENATOR
ALLEN, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. I JUST
WANT TO ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES
AND THANK SENATOR CORTEZ FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. TAIWAN,
CALIFORNIA AND OUR IN OUR
NATION, THE UNITED STATES HAVE
LONG MAINTAINED SHARED VALUES OF
A STRONG DEMOCRACY, FREE AND
FAIR SOCIETY BUILT ON HUMAN
RIGHTS, HONEST ELECTIONS, RULE
OF LAW THAT SERVES PEOPLE. AND I
ALSO WANT TO JUST TAKE A MOMENT
TO GIVE A SPECIAL SHOUT OUT TO
THE TAIWANESE AMERICAN COMMUNITY
THAT LIVES THROUGHOUT OUR
BEAUTIFUL STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
MANY OF THEM LIVE LIVING IN ALL
OF OUR DISTRICTS, AND THEY'VE
CONTRIBUTED SO IMMENSELY TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. SO THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO CELEBRATE
THE VIBRANT CULTURE, THE
ACHIEVEMENTS AND THE SHARED
VALUES THAT WE HAVE WITH TAIWAN
AND OUR WONDERFUL TAIWANESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SENATOR.
SENATOR CORTEZ, YOU MAY CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? WE ARE NOT GOING TO
USE THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ROLL.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI, GIL. HI, ARCHULETA.
HI, ASHBY. HI, ATKINS. HI
BECKER. HI, BLAKESBURG. HI
BRADFORD. HI, CABALLERO. CORTEZ
HI. DAWLEY HI, DODD. HI DURAZZO.
I EGGMAN I GLAESER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE I OTERO I JONES. LAIRD I
LIMON I MCGUIRE MENGIBAR I MIN I
NEWMAN NGUYEN I NILA I TRUMBO I
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO I SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I STERN I
UMBERG WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CABALLERO JONES, MCGUIRE.
NEWMAN. UMBERG AYES 35. NO ZERO.
THE RESOLUTION PASSES FILED.
ITEM 48. SENATOR SKINNER. SHE IS
READY. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION 117 BY SENATOR
SKINNER, RELATIVE TO THE EAST
BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICTS 90TH
ANNIVERSARY. SENATOR SKINNER,
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
THIS SENATE RESOLUTION HONORING
THE EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK
DISTRICT'S 90TH ANNIVERSARY. THE
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT
IS THE LARGEST URBAN PARK
DISTRICT IN THE UNITED STATES.
IT COVERS OVER 125,000 ACRES IN
TWO COUNTIES, ALAMEDA COUNTY AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. AND THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE EITHER FAMILIAR
WITH IT OR WHO LIVE IN EITHER OF
THOSE COUNTIES, KNOW THAT THAT'S
ONE OF THE BEST ASPECTS OF
LIVING THERE IS HAVING THAT
ACCESS TO WHETHER IT IS OUR
SHORELINE PARKS ALONG THE BAY,
THE HILLS, THE DELTA, IT'S JUST
UNBELIEVABLE. THE DIVERSITY OF
THOSE PARKS, FROM TILDEN PARK,
WHICH WAS THE FIRST OF THE EAST
BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICTS. AND
WHEN I SAY ITS 90TH ANNIVERSARY,
THE EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK
DISTRICT WAS FOUNDED DURING THE
DEEP, DEEP DEPRESSION WHEN THE
VOTERS EVEN WITH I MEAN, THAT
WAS THE WORST DEPRESSION WE'VE
YET HAD. AND THE VOTERS OF THE
EAST BAY DECIDED TO TAX
THEMSELVES IN ORDER TO PRESERVE
THE HILLSIDES AS OPEN SPACE. AND
SO IT'S BEEN IN EXISTENCE. ALL
THOSE YEARS AND FUNDED BY ALL
THE RESIDENTS OF BOTH COUNTIES.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS, I INVITE
YOU TO CELEBRATE THE 90 YEARS OF
THAT LAND PRESERVATION,
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSERVATION AND
RECREATION ACCESS BY SUPPORTING
THIS RESOLUTION. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. I, SENATOR GLAZER,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS,
THE SENATOR FROM BERKELEY AND I
SHARE THESE GREAT LANDS
PROTECTED BY THE EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT. AND I
CERTAINLY JOIN IN URGING SUPPORT
FOR THE RESOLUTION HONORING THEM
ON THEIR 90TH ANNIVERSARY.
SEEING NO OTHER MICS UP, SENATOR
SKINNER, YOU MAY CLOSE. I ASK
FOR YOUR. I VOTE. THANK YOU.
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 36. NO ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION PASSES. WE ARE NOW ON
ITEM 52. SENATOR RUBIO IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE RESOLUTION 121 BY SENATOR
RUBIO, RELATIVE TO VETERAN
HOUSING AND SECURITY AWARENESS
MONTH. SENATOR RUBIO, THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT SR 121, WHICH
PROCLAIMS NOVEMBER 2024 AS
VETERAN HOUSING AND SECURITY
AWARENESS MONTH. SENATORS
ACCORDING TO THE 2022 HOUSING
ASSISTANCE COUNCIL REPORT, THE
PERCENTAGE OF CALIFORNIA
VETERANS WITH A VA DETERMINED
SERVICE CONNECTED DISABILITY WAS
24.7%. WAY TO MANY OF OUR
VETERANS ARE SACRIFICING THEIR
HEALTH AND THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR US, AND WE MUST DO BETTER.
THIS RESOLUTION SHINES A LIGHT
ON THESE VETERAN HOUSING AND
SECURITY ISSUES, WHICH CAN BE
DETRIMENTAL TO THE LIVELIHOOD OF
OUR SERVICE MEMBERS WHEN THEY
COME HOME. VETERANS HAVE GIVEN
SO MUCH OF THEIR LIFE AND TIME
FOR US TO BE HERE, AND WE HAVE
TO ENSURE THAT WHEN THEY RETURN,
THEY HAVE THE VERY BASIC
NECESSITIES, WHICH IS HOUSING.
WE MUST CONTINUE TO PUSH STATE
AND FEDERAL POLICIES TO ENSURE
WE PROVIDE SUFFICIENT HOUSING
AND RESOURCES TO THOSE THAT ARE
MOST VULNERABLE. I WAS PLEASED
TO SEE THE RECENT ANNOUNCEMENT
LAST WEEK FROM THE BIDEN-HARRIS
ADMINISTRATION REGARDING THE NEW
SET OF CHANGES TO HELP MORE
VETERANS RECEIVE ASSISTANCE
UNDER THE HUD VA PROGRAM. THESE
ACTIONS WILL IMPROVE ACCESS TO
SUPPORTING SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT FOR OUR VETERANS,
OUR VETERANS WHO HAVE SACRIFICED
AGAINST SO MUCH MUST HAVE THE
VERY BASIC NECESSITIES TO LIVE
IN DIGNITY AND RECEIVE AT LEAST
THE VERY MINIMUM, WHICH IS
HOUSING AND OUR APPRECIATION FOR
THEIR SERVICE. THANK YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR. SEEING
NO MIKES UP, THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL.
ANY OBJECTION? I'M SEEING NONE.
AYES 36. NO ZERO. RESOLUTION
PASSES.
UP NEXT IS FINAL ITEM 53 BY
SENATOR ROTH. HE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION 122 BY SENATOR ROTH.
RELATIVE TO CHILDHOOD CANCER
AWARENESS MONTH. SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. THIS
RESOLUTION RECOGNIZES SEPTEMBER
AS CHILDHOOD CANCER AWARENESS
MONTH. ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN
CHILDHOOD CANCER ORGANIZATION,
CANCER IS THE LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH BY DISEASE AMONG CHILDREN
IN CALIFORNIA AND IN THE UNITED
STATES. THE RESOLUTION SEEKS TO
RAISE AWARENESS OF CHILDHOOD
CANCER AND THE IMPACT THAT IT
HAS, NOT ONLY ON THE CHILD
AFFLICTED, BUT ON THE FAMILY
CARING FOR THEM AS WELL. THESE
FAMILIES, WHILE DEALING WITH THE
EMOTIONAL TOLL OF A DIAGNOSIS
AND CARING FOR THEIR SICK CHILD,
ARE THEN BURDENED WITH THE
CHALLENGES OF NAVIGATING A
CONFUSING HEALTH CARE SYSTEM,
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW MUCH
TIME THEY CAN TAKE OFF FROM
WORK, AND WORRYING IF THEIR
FAMILY CAN FINANCIALLY HANDLE
THE IMPACT OF THE DISEASE, WHEN
WHAT THEY SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON
IS THE SON OR DAUGHTER FIGHTING
FOR THEIR LIFE. I'VE MET WITH
MOTHERS IN MY DISTRICT WHO HAVE
A CHILD WITH CANCER, AND I CAN
TELL YOU THESE ARE SOME OF THE
MOST RESILIENT FOLKS THAT I'VE
EVER HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
MEETING. THE ISSUES ARE REAL,
AND THEY ARE THE TRUE FIGHTERS
AND THE TRUE ADVOCATES IN THIS
ARENA. OUR STATE HAS CLEARLY LED
THE WAY IN CANCER TREATMENT AND
IS HOME TO MANY OF THE WORLD'S
FINEST CANCER TREATMENT
FACILITIES. ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA
HAS SET THE BENCHMARK FOR CANCER
TREATMENT, WE STILL HAVE A LONG
WAY TO GO IN EXPANDING AWARENESS
AND IN PROVIDING WORKPLACE AND
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR THESE
FAMILIES OF CANCER PATIENTS IN
THEIR TIME OF NEED. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE, BUT I ASK MEMBERS, IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON
THIS RESOLUTION? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN RODA-GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPUR. AYE BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE. DALY
AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE. AYE OR DATO. AYE.
JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE LIMON.
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I MEAN
AYE. NEWMAN. NGUYEN. AYE NHIÀU.
AYE BORG. AYE. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER I SMILED.
CUEVAS. AYE STERN. AYE UMBERG.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
SEN ROTHMAN MOVES A COUPLE
MEMBERS. WE HAVE SOME SPECIAL
GUESTS ON OUR FLOOR. I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR STERN AND HIS
FAMILY. WIFE ALEXANDRA, DAUGHTER
AVA AND SON LEONARD. WE WELCOME
ALL OF YOU TO THE SENATE. Þ
GOOD. WAVING THE FLAG. WHAT A
TREAT TO HAVE YOU ALL HERE.
THANK YOU. HENRY. THANK YOU.
GOOD TO SEE YOUR FAMILY. THANK
YOU GUYS. HEY, CAN SHE SAY ONE
THING? POINT OF ORDER. SENATOR
STERN, FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU
RISE? A POINT, A POINT OF ORDER.
PLEASE STATE YOUR POINT, SIR.
THE. MY MOST IMPORTANT
CONSTITUENTS HAVE SOMETHING TO
SAY. EXACTLY. ONE OF THEM LOVES
HIS MOM, TOO MUCH. AND BY THE
WAY, THIS IS WHERE I FELL IN
LOVE WITH MY WIFE. ON THIS
FLOOR. STANDING HERE WHEN YOU
HONORED HER FATHER, AND WE. WE
STOOD ON THIS FLOOR. SO I WANT
TO THANK THE SENATE FOR BEING
PART OF THIS LOVE AFFAIR THAT
HAS GIVEN US LIFE. AND, AVA, DID
YOU WANT TO SAY ANYTHING INTO
THE MICROPHONE REAL QUICK?
THROUGH THE CHAIR. THERE YOU GO.
FULLER. C . YEAH. AND THEN WHAT
ELSE? I LOVE CALIFORNIA Ó. I
THINK SHE SAID, I LOVE
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, FOR THE INDULGENCE.
THANK YOU ALL FOR SUPPORTING ME.
AND THIS FAMILY. IT'S SUCH AN
HONOR TO GROW WITH YOU ALL AND,
SENATOR STERN, YOUR POINT OF
ORDER IS RULED OUT OF ORDER. I
KNOW, SORRY, BERNIE. SORRY,
BERNIE. WE'RE GOING TO CALL THAT
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR IN
HINDSIGHT AND WE. SO I RECOGNIZE
AND THANK AND YOUR YOUR LOVELY
WIFE FOR MARRYING YOU AND FOR
YOUR FAMILY BEING HERE ON THE
FLOOR. ALL RIGHT. OKAY MEMBERS,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 54. THIS IS SR 123 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE RESOLUTION
123 BY SENATOR MENGIBAR RELATIVE
TO SALVADORAN-AMERICAN DAY.
SENATOR MENGIBAR, YOU WANT TO DO
IT FROM THE MAJORITY LEADER'S
DESK? ALL RIGHT. WE RECOGNIZE
SENATOR MENGIBAR FROM THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK, MA'AM.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, TODAY I RISE FOR SR
123. AS A PROUD DAUGHTER OF
SALVADORAN IMMIGRANTS, I'M
HONORED TO BRING FORTH THE
RESOLUTION RECOGNIZING SEPTEMBER
1ST AS SALVADORAN AMERICAN DAY.
AS THE LATINO COMMUNITY
CONTINUES TO GROW IN THIS GREAT
STATE, IT IS IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE DIVERSITY WITHIN
THAT UMBRELLA AND THE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE GREAT STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THE HISTORY OF EL
SALVADOR IN CALIFORNIA IS RICH
AND ENDURING TAPESTRY WOVEN WITH
THE THREADS OF MANY REMARKABLE
LIVES, CULTURES, AND EVENTS IN
FACT, I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE IN THAT COUNTRY LAST
OCTOBER WHERE A DELEGATION OF
SENATORS WENT TO MY PARENTS
HOMELAND AND GOT TO WITNESS
EVERYTHING THAT OUR SALVADOR HAS
TO OFFER AND CHANGE. SO I THANK
THE SENATORS FROM LA, FROM MENLO
PARK, FROM SANTA MONICA, WHO
JOINED ME ON THAT TRIP.
SALVADORAN AMERICANS CONSTITUTE
ONE OF THE LARGEST LATINO
COMMUNITIES NATIONWIDE, TOTALING
2.5 MILLION. THE LARGEST
DIASPORA HERE IN CALIFORNIA. 32%
OF SALVADORAN IMMIGRANTS RESIDE
IN CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES. MANY OF THESE ADMIRABLE
INDIVIDUALS ACTIVELY PARTICIPATE
IN THE STATE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM,
FURTHER PROMOTING THEIR SENSE OF
AMERICAN PRIDE WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY. AND 1994,
THE STATE SENATE WELCOMED THEIR
FIRST EVER SALVADORAN AMERICAN
SENATOR, SENATOR LIZ FIGUEROA,
WHO THEN RETIRED IN 2006. FAST
FORWARD TO 2022, YOU ALL
WELCOMED ME AS THE SECOND
SALVADORAN AMERICAN TO BE
ELECTED TO THE STATE SENATE, AND
I WELCOME AND I'M JOINED BY THE
25% A QUARTER SALVADORIAN
MEXICAN AMERICAN MAJORITY LEADER
OVER THERE. I STAND FIRM
ALONGSIDE MY ANCESTORS IN THE
SALVADORAN LEGISLATORS BEFORE ME
IN BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION
FORWARD SO THAT THE STRENGTHS OF
THE AMERICAN, THE SALVADORAN
AMERICAN CULTURE, CAN BE
PRESERVED AND PASSED ON TO
FUTURE GENERATIONS RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR NO VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR MENJIVAR, ON THE
RESOLUTION. SENATOR BECKER. HI,
JOSE. BRIEFLY, AS SOMEONE WHO
SPENT A LOT OF TIME IN THE
WONDERFUL COUNTRY OF EL SALVADOR
AND JOINED IN ON THE DELEGATION,
I WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR AND
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION TO HONOR
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE
SALVADORAN COMMUNITY TO OUR
STATE AND COUNTRY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR BECKER.
SENATOR OCHOA BOGH. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY TO
THANK SENATOR MENGIBAR FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORWARD,
THIS RESOLUTION CELEBRATING THE
SALVADORAN HERITAGE IN OUR
COUNTRY. I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT I AM A RECIPIENT OF AN
AMAZING FIELD REPRESENTATIVE
IMMIGRANT FROM EL SALVADOR, WHO
IS ONE OF THE HARDEST WORKING,
PASSIONATE, ALL PATRIOTIC
AMERICAN WHO REALLY EMBODIES THE
AMERICAN DREAM. AS AN IMMIGRANT
FROM EL SALVADOR WHO HAS
ACCOMPLISHED SO MUCH SINCE
ARRIVING TO THIS COUNTRY. AND
I'M GRATEFUL, GRATEFUL FOR THAT
HERITAGE AND THAT WORK ETHIC AND
THAT HEART FOR OUR COUNTRY. SO
GRATEFUL THAT YOU BROUGHT THIS
MEASURE FORWARD. I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT MY FIELD
REPRESENTATIVE, ARMANDO MARTINEZ,
WITH THIS AMAZING AND BEAUTIFUL
HERITAGE BEHIND HIM. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SENATOR DURAZO, THANK
YOU. I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. WE'RE
VERY, VERY PROUD TO HAVE YOU
REPRESENTING THE SALVADORAN
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA. AND
ALSO A BIG SHOUT OUT TO THE
SALVADORAN COMMUNITY IN MY
DISTRICT, WHICH IS A VERY, VERY
VIBRANT, INVOLVED, CIVICALLY
INVOLVED COMMUNITY. AND I'M VERY
PROUD TO REPRESENT THEM. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR DURAZO.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS RESOLUTION? MEMBERS,
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SEEING NONE. SENATOR MENGIBAR,
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING IN,
ASKING FOR A VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION. I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR MY VOTE. ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
OBJECTIONS. AYES 36. NO. ZERO.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
55. THIS IS SHR 124 BY SENATOR
CABALLERO. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE RESOLUTION 124 BY
SENATOR CABALLERO. RELATIVE TO
RECOGNIZING THE UNITED MEXICAN
STATES FIRST WOMAN PRESIDENT,
DOCTOR CLAUDIA SHEINBAUM.
SENATOR CHAVIRA, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, I RISE
TO PRESENT SHR 124, WHICH
RECOGNIZES AND CONGRATULATES THE
UNITED MEXICAN STATES FOR THE
HISTORIC ACHIEVEMENT IN ELECTING
ITS FIRST FEMALE PRESIDENT.
DOCTOR CLAUDIA SHEINBAUM, IN ITS
203 YEAR HISTORY, THE UNITED
MEXICAN STATES HAS ACHIEVED A
SIGNIFICANT MILESTONE THROUGH A
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS WITH THE
ELECTION OF DOCTOR SHEINBAUM,
HER ELECTION REPRESENTS A MAJOR
ADVANCEMENT IN GENDER EQUITY AND
A NOTABLE SHIFT IN THE GLOBAL
POLITICAL LANDSCAPE. THIS MAJOR
ACHIEVEMENT IS HIGHLIGHTED BY
THE FACT THAT DOCTOR CLAUDIA
SHEINBAUM IS THE FIRST FEMALE TO
BE ELECTED PRESIDENT. AMONG THE
THREE LARGEST NORTH AMERICAN
COUNTRIES, CANADA AND THE UNITED
STATES. DOCTOR SHEINBAUM IS A
WOMAN OF FIRSTS. SHE WILL ALSO
BE THE FIRST MEXICAN PRESIDENT
WITH A PREDOMINANT,
PREDOMINANTLY JEWISH BACKGROUND.
SHE EARNED HER PHD IN ENERGY
ENGINEERING FROM THE UNAM
NATIONAL AUTONOMOUS UNIVERSITY
OF MEXICO, AND CONDUCTED
RESEARCH AT THE LAWRENCE
BERKELEY NATIONAL LABORATORY.
HAS AN IMPRESSIVE BACKGROUND IN
BOTH SCIENCE AND PUBLIC SERVICE.
HER PREVIOUS ROLES INCLUDE
SERVING AS SECRETARY OF THE
ENVIRONMENT FOR THE UNITED
MEXICAN STATES AND AS MAYOR OF
MEXICO CITY, A CITY OF OVER 22
MILLION INHABITANTS IN THE
METROPOLITAN REGION. HER
CONTRIBUTIONS EXTEND BEYOND
POLITICS. SHE WAS PART OF THE
UNITED NATIONS INTERGOVERNMENTAL
PANEL ON CLIMATE CHANGE THAT
RECEIVED THE 2007 NOBEL NOBEL
PEACE PRIZE, AND HER WORK IN
CLIMATE SCIENCE AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT UNDERSCORES HER
COMMITMENT TO PROGRESS AND
SUSTAINABILITY. HISTORICALLY,
MEXICO MAINTAINS STRONG
CULTURAL, HISTORICAL, SOCIAL,
AND ECONOMIC TIES WITH
CALIFORNIA THROUGH ITS HISTORY,
BORDER, AND PEOPLE. AS THE
WORLD'S TEN MOST POPULOUS
COUNTRY, MEXICO IS THE SECOND
LARGEST EXPORT PARTNER AND THE
LARGEST SOURCE OF IMPORTS FROM
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
THE ELECTED ELECTION OF DOCTOR
SHEINBAUM REPRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT STEP FORWARD IN
ADVANCING GENDER EQUITY BY
BREAKING LONG STANDING BARRIERS
AND SETTING A POWERFUL PRECEDENT
FOR WOMEN'S LEADERSHIP. HER HER
PRESIDENCY WILL INSPIRE YOUNG
GIRLS AND WOMEN, PARTICULARLY
WOMEN OF COLOR, ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND THE WORLD,
ENCOURAGING GREATER INVOLVEMENT
IN POLITICS, STEM FIELDS, AND
CLIMATE CHANGE. FURTHERMORE, HER
EXCELLENCE IN VARIOUS FIELDS
WILL, WILL INSPIRE PRIDE AMONG
MEXICANS WORLDWIDE AND ENCOURAGE
A COMMITMENT TO LEARNING AND
EXCELLENCE IN ALL ENDEAVORS. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA LOOKS
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
PRESIDENT ELECT SHEINBAUM AND
HER ADMINISTRATION TO STRENGTHEN
OUR RELATIONSHIP AND STRENGTHEN
THE PARTNERSHIPS AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO COLLABORATE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SENATOR SKINNER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I WANT TO
APPRECIATE OUR COLLEAGUE FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION. I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF MEETING WITH,
DOCTOR SHEINBAUM, PRESIDENT
SHEINBAUM, A NUMBER OF TIMES,
WHILE SHE WAS THE SECRETARY OF
ENVIRONMENT AND ALSO MAYOR OF
MEXICO CITY WHEN I WAS DOING THE
WORK WITH CITIES FOR RUNNING
CITIES FOR CLIMATE PROTECTION.
AND WE HAD AN OFFICE IN MEXICO
CITY. AND WHILE SHE WAS
SECRETARY OF ENVIRONMENT, SHE
SPOKE AT MANY OF OUR EVENTS AND
GAVE A, IMPARTED HER SCIENTIFIC
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE CLIMATE
CRISIS AS OUR COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED, SHE WAS ONE OF THE
NOBEL PRIZE WINNERS FOR BEING
PART OF THE INTERNATIONAL PANEL
ON THE SCIENTIST PANEL AROUND
THE CLIMATE CRISIS. AND SHE
WOULD IMPART THAT KNOWLEDGE. AND
THEN IN HER POLITICAL ROLE AS
MAYOR, SHE WOULD PRESENT AT THE
VARIOUS CONFERENCE OF PARTIES OF
THE UNITED NATIONS, WHERE THEY
NEGOTIATED ISSUES AROUND
CLIMATE, BUT IN ADDITION TO
THAT, WHEN SHE WON, SHE IN HER
INAUGURAL ADDRESS, I WAS VERY
STRUCK BY THIS COMMENT THAT SHE
MADE. AND AS CHAIR OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS OF PERMISSION TO
READ WITHOUT OBJECTION, IN HER
INAUGURAL STATEMENT, I DO NOT
ARRIVE ALONE. WE ALL ARRIVED
WITH OUR HEROINES, OUR HEROINES
WHO GAVE US OUR HOMELAND, WITH
OUR MOTHERS, OUR DAUGHTERS, AND
OUR GRANDDAUGHTERS. SHE IS
ANOTHER PROOF, AND I HOPE TO SEE
MORE PROOF OF THAT. THIS IS THE
YEAR OF WOMEN. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SENATOR RUBIO, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I ALSO RISE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SR 124. AND IT
GIVES ME GREAT PRIDE TO HONOR
DOCTOR CLAUDIA SHEINBAUM AS THE
FIRST FEMALE MEXICAN PRESIDENT.
I ALSO HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
VISITING MEXICO AND SPENDING
TIME WITH HER, AND ANYONE THAT
HAS SPENT TIME WITH HER CAN SEE
HOW INTELLIGENT SHE IS PREPARED
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY, CARES VERY
MUCH ABOUT COMMUNITY AND CLIMATE
ISSUES. I WANTED TO JUST SHARE
THAT THERE'S SO MUCH WE CAN
LEARN FROM THE EXPERTISE THAT
SHE BRINGS TO THE TABLE, AS
SHARED BY THE GREAT SENATOR FROM
BERKELEY AND THE SENATOR FROM
MERCED. YOU KNOW, SHE IS REALLY
FOCUSED ON CLIMATE ISSUES, AND I
WAS SO IMPRESSED WITH THE
ADVANCES THAT THEY'VE MADE IN
MEXICO. AND SHE WAS SO WILLING
TO SHARE, TALK ABOUT THAT WORK.
AND I THINK THAT WE HAVE A GREAT
PARTNER IN MEXICO, AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HER. AND
AGAIN, AS A MEXICAN BORN
SENATOR, IT IS REALLY
INCREDIBLY, YOU KNOW, A PROUD
MOMENT FOR ME THAT MEXICO IS NOW
UPLIFTING WOMEN IN SUCH A GREAT
WAY. AND I HOPE THAT WE FOLLOW
SUIT, BECAUSE IT'S TIME THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE THAT WOMEN
BRING TO THE TABLE. AND WITH
THAT, I'M PROUD TO BE A
PRINCIPLE COAUTHOR ON THIS
RESOLUTION. AND I URGE AND I
VOTE THANK YOU. SENATOR DURAZZO.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU.
GRACIAS A LA SENORA. THE MERCED
POR HABER PRESENTADO ESTA
RESOLUTION FELICIDADES A LA
DOCTORA CLAUDIA SHEINBAUM. YO
SOY MÉXICO AMERICANA Y ESTOY MUY
ORGULLOSA C¯ SI ELEGIDA COMO LA
PRIMERA MUJER PRESIDENTE DE LOS
ESTADOS UNIDOS MEXICANOS.
GRACIAS THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SENATOR GROVE, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I TOO, RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION. AND
I APPRECIATE PRESIDENT BAUM'S
EXTRAORDINARY CONFIDENCE IN
DOMESTIC ENERGY PRODUCTION. WE
ACTUALLY IMPORT ROUGHLY 13
MILLION BARRELS OF OIL FROM
MEXICO EVERY SINGLE, EVERY
SINGLE YEAR. CALIFORNIA NEEDS
THAT OIL PRODUCTION, AND WE GET
IT FROM FOREIGN SOURCES. AND SHE
ALSO KNOWS THAT DOMESTIC
SECURITY AND DOMESTIC ENERGY ON
THIS SIDE OF THE CONTINENT IS
MOST VALUABLE AND MOST IMPORTANT.
SHE ALSO KNOWS THAT IT'S A
HIGHER CONCENTRATION OF CARBON
EMISSIONS TO IMPORT OIL FROM
SAUDI ARABIA, ECUADOR AND OTHER
PLACES. AND SHE HAS TAKEN A
STAND THAT PROVIDES
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY OIL,
THE MOST RESTRICTIVE OIL AND THE
MOST ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY
OIL ON THIS SIDE OF THE
CONTINENT, WHERE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCES, WHERE WE'RE NOT
PRODUCING ANY MORE. BUT WE ARE
RELYING ON OTHER FOREIGN SOURCES
OF OIL. BUT SHE IS AN ALLY IN
THIS INDUSTRY BECAUSE SHE
REALIZES THAT PRODUCING IT HERE
IS THE SAFEST WAY POSSIBLE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE MEET THE NEEDS
THAT WE HAVE. AND AGAIN,
CREATING A DOMESTIC SECURITY
SOURCE, AS WELL AS MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE OIL PRODUCED HERE
IN OUR STATE AND ON THIS SIDE OF
THE CONTINENT. SO I APPRECIATE
HER STANCE. I APPRECIATE HER
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY, WHICH
INCLUDES DOMESTIC OIL AND ENERGY
PRODUCTION AND THE RISKS THAT WE
HAVE BRINGING OIL FROM FOREIGN
SOURCES. AND I SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION. SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATOR
CABALLERO, YOU MAY CLOSE RESPECT
FOR YOUR RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS. THANK
YOU. SENATOR SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA Ã ASHBY.
AYE ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE AYE.
BLAKE SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE OR DATO
AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LIMÓN. AYE MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN. NGUYEN
MAIELLO. AYE JOBO. AYE PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER
AZEMAR. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE
UMBERG. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE
WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN MCGUIRE. NEWMAN
NGUYEN. UMBERG DIAZ. AYES 35. NÓ
ZERO ZERO. THE RESOLUTION
PASSES. COLLEAGUES. THAT IS IT
FOR THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION ON
RESOLUTIONS. UNLESS SOMETHING
ELSE COMES UP, THAT SHOULD BE IT
FOR THE SENATE. THIRD READING,
THIRD READING. JUST KIDDING.
JUST FOR OUR RESOLUTIONS, WE ARE
NOW MOVING INTO ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING. FOR MORE RESOLUTIONS,
WE HAVE FIVE ITEMS. ITEMS 99. SO
YOU'RE READY. 3033 27, 335 AND
345 FOR ITEM FILE 99. SENATOR
WIENER IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCKENNA. RELATIVE TO
HOUSING. SENATOR WIENER, THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKENNA,
WHICH URGES THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS TO PASS AND FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO SIGN THREE
IMPORTANT HOUSING BILLS THAT
WILL HELP ADDRESS OUR HOUSING
SHORTAGE, IMPROVE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE, AND PROVIDE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR FIRST
TIME HOME BUYERS. H.R. 4233
WOULD INVEST MORE THAN $150
BILLION IN AFFORDABLE AND
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING, HOUSING
VOUCHERS, HOUSING PRESERVATION,
AND OTHER HOUSING INVESTMENTS,
CREATING 1.4 MILLION AFFORDABLE
HOMES. H.R. 4232 WOULD REDUCE
POVERTY IN AMERICA BY
TRANSFORMING THE HOUSING CHOICE
VOUCHER PROGRAM INTO A FEDERAL
ENTITLEMENT, ALLOWING EVERY
HOUSEHOLD THAT QUALIFIES FOR
ASSISTANCE TO RECEIVE IT. IT
WOULD ALSO BAN HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON INCOME
AND VETERAN STATUS. H.R. 4231
WOULD PROVIDE $100 BILLION IN
DIRECT ASSISTANCE TO HELP FIRST
TIME, FIRST GENERATION HOME
BUYERS PURCHASE THEIR FIRST
HOME. WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF A
HOUSING CRISIS DRIVEN BY A
NATIONWIDE SHORTAGE OF MILLIONS
OF HOMES. FEDERAL INVESTMENT IS
CRITICAL FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOMES, AND THE
LEGISLATION SUPPORTED BY THIS
RESOLUTION WOULD PROVIDE THAT
CRITICAL INVESTMENT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, SEEING
NO MIX UP SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO GILL.
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE. DAWLEY
DODD. AYE. D'ORAZIO. AYE EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE OTERO. AYE. JONES LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MAGUIRE
MENJIVAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN MAIELLO. OKOBO PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO. NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
AYE. AYE. UMBER WAHHAB. AYE
WIENER. AYE. WILK SEN. WIENER
MOVES A CALL. MOVING ON TO ITEM
303. SENATOR JONES IS READY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ THE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
182 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DIXON.
RELATIVE TO OCEAN POLLUTION.
SENATOR JONES, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND SENATORS, I RISE
TO PRESENT ACR 182 BY OUR
COLLEAGUE IN THE ASSEMBLY,
ASSEMBLYWOMAN DIXON. THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION WAS
INTRODUCED TO BRING AWARENESS TO
THE MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF MARINE
GARBAGE THAT IS IMPACTING OUR
OCEANS, WILDLIFE, ECOSYSTEM,
HEALTH AND ACCESS, OPPORTUNITY
TO RECREATION IN THE OCEAN.
WHETHER A SURFER, AN ANGLER, OR
JUST AN ADMIRER OF THE OCEAN,
MOST CALIFORNIANS ARE ARE
INVESTED CONSERVATIONISTS. IT IS
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF EACH OF US
TO ENSURE THAT OCEAN RESOURCES
ARE MANAGED FOR THE BENEFIT OF
ALL STAKEHOLDERS, BOTH NOW AND
FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS. THIS
RESOLUTION RIGHTFULLY DIRECTS
ATTENTION TO SOME OF THE MORE
MEANINGFUL AND DIFFICULT
CHALLENGES TO SOLVE, INCLUDING
REDUCING PLASTIC WASTE, THE
GREAT PACIFIC GARBAGE PATCH
ENCOMPASSES 618,000MI² OF THE
PACIFIC OCEAN. SENATORS. THAT'S
TWICE THE SIZE OF TEXAS. ACR 182
PROVIDES THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
THIS CONSERVATION AND BRING TO
LIGHT THESE ISSUES. YOU MAY
REMEMBER WHILE WE WERE DEBATING
SB 54 A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO,
THAT I MENTIONED A STORY OF
BEING DOWN IN OAXACA, MEXICO,
WITH OUR COLLEAGUE, SENATOR BEN
HUESO, AND DOING A TOUR ON THE
OCEAN AND THE, THE, THE STREAM,
THE OCEAN STREAM THAT WAS
POLLUTED WITH ICE CHESTS, LAWN
CHAIRS, STYROFOAM, PLASTIC
BOTTLES. AND I THINK THERE WAS
EVEN A BOWLING BALL FLOATING
THROUGH THE NØ. THAT'S BUT
THAT'S HOW BAD IT WAS. AND THAT
WE ACTUALLY HAD TO TIME IN THE
IN THE LITTLE FISHING BOAT THAT
WE HAD TO TIME OUR CROSSING OF
THAT STREAM IN THE OCEAN TO GET
TO THE OTHER SIDE TO CONTINUE
OUR FISHING TRIP. SO ACR 182
PROVIDES THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
THIS CONSERVATION AND BRING TO
LIGHT THESE ISSUES. IT SEEKS TO
PROMOTE AND ENCOURAGE SOLUTIONS
TO ENSURING OUR OCEANS AND
COASTLINES ARE CLEAN AND
HEALTHY, AND SEEKS TO FIND WAYS
TO ELIMINATE THE GREAT PACIFIC
GARBAGE PATCH. PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DIXON AND MYSELF
IN VOTING AYE ON ACR 182.
SENATOR SHAKESPEARE, THANK YOU.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS. WE
NEED TO ELIMINATE THE LARGEST
PLASTIC ACCUMULATION ZONE IN THE
WORLD AND I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SENATOR JONES, YOU MAY
CLOSE. SENATOR JONES, YOU MAY
CLOSE. PLEASE VOTE AYE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE. DALY AYE.
DODD. AYE DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE AYE OR DATO. AYE. JONES
AYE. AYE. LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN. AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN NGUYEN. AYE YELLOW. AYE.
OCHOA AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. AYE SKINNER. I
SMILED. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE SENATOR JONES MOVES
THE CALL, MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
327 SEN. SPEAR THE SENATOR IS
READY. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION 18 BY
ASSEMBLY. MEMBER DAVIES.
RELATIVE TO NUCLEAR FUEL.
SENATOR SPEAR, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, TODAY I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AGR 18 ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLYWOMAN DAVIES. THE
ESSENCE IS TO ASK THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO ADVANCE ITS OWN
NUCLEAR COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATIONS AND FINALLY GET
SPENT NUCLEAR FUEL OUT OF OUR
STATE AND INTO CONSENT BASED
SITES APPROVED BY THE FEDERAL
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY. SENATORS.
BACK IN 1998, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WAS LEGALLY OBLIGATED
TO WORK WITH STATES WHO HAD
NUCLEAR FACILITIES IN THEIR
STATES TO FIND SAFE AND SECURE
PLACES TO STORE EXCESS NUCLEAR
FUEL. CALIFORNIA, AS YOU KNOW,
HAS AND HAD FACILITIES IN
SACRAMENTO, SAN LUIS OBISPO, SAN
DIEGO AND HUMBOLDT COUNTIES.
AFTER MORE THAN 25 YEARS, WE ARE
STILL WAITING. NOTHING HAS BEEN
DONE IN OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
SUFFERING FOR IT. AS NOTED BY
THE SUPPORTERS OF AGR 18, SINCE
2000, U.S. TAXPAYERS HAVE HAD TO
PAY $10.6 BILLION IN DAMAGES TO
COVER COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH ON
SITE NUCLEAR STORAGE THAT HASN'T
BEEN MOVED YET. THIS IS A
POSITION US ENERGY SECRETARY
GRANHOLM HAS ENDORSED, BUT NEEDS
CONGRESS TO AUTHORIZE THE MOVE.
THIS RESOLUTION IS NOT HERE TO
DEBATE THE MERITS OF NUCLEAR
ENERGY. IT IS SIMPLY A TOOL TO
SHOW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
THE WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IS READY FOR THEM TO
START ACTING, AND TO MOVE
FORWARD EXPEDITIOUSLY, TO REMOVE
SPENT NUCLEAR WASTE. THIS
RESOLUTION PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
WITH NO NO VOTES AND PASSED
SENATE UTILITIES AND ENERGY WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AS WELL. THIS
RESOLUTION IS SUPPORTED BY
MULTIPLE CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE,
OUR STATE PARKS FOUNDATION, UC
SAN DIEGO, A LOCAL NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBE, AND MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON AGR 18.
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYWOMAN
DAVIES. THANK YOU. SENATOR SENO,
MIKE. SUP, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKESBURG. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD. AYE. D'ORAZIO
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
NGUYEN. AYE. NAHOLO. AYE. OKOBO
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER. I SMILED.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE
SEN. BLAKESBERG MOVES A CALL.
MOVING ON TO FIVE. ITEM 335.
SENATOR CORTESE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO 11 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. COLLURA
RELATIVE TO CRICKET. SENATOR
CORTESE, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND SENATORS. I RISE
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA TO PRESENT ACR 211, A
RESOLUTION THAT ENCOURAGES THE
CALIFORNIA INTERSCHOLASTIC
FEDERATION TO RECOGNIZE CRICKET
AS AN OFFICIAL HIGH SCHOOL SPORT.
CRICKET IS A GAME THAT
ORIGINATED IN THE UNITED KINGDOM
IN THE 19TH CENTURY, AND QUICKLY
SPREAD TO MANY OF ITS FORMER
COLONIES AND NEIGHBORING
COUNTRIES, INCLUDING INDIA,
PAKISTAN, AND AUSTRALIA. SINCE
THEN, IT HAS ACHIEVED IMMENSE
POPULARITY HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES, CULTIVATING THRIVING
PLAYER AND FAN COMMUNITIES HERE
AND ACROSS THE WORLD. THIS
INCLUDES THE UNITED STATES AS A
WHOLE, WHERE OVER 200,000 PEOPLE
PLAY THE GAME. CALIFORNIA'S
POSITION ITSELF AS ONE OF THE
HUBS OF THE AMERICAN CRICKET,
HOSTING TWO OF THE SIX MAJOR
LEAGUE CRICKET TEAMS AND
PREPARING TO REINTRODUCE CRICKET
AS AN OFFICIAL OLYMPIC SPORT AT
THE UPCOMING 2028 LOS ANGELES
SUMMER OLYMPICS. CRICKET ALSO
HOLDS A PARTICULAR IMPORTANCE
FOR MANY MEMBERS OF OUR STATE'S
SOUTH ASIAN DIASPORA, WHO
CONSIDER IT INTEGRAL TO THEIR
HISTORICAL AND CULTURAL
HERITAGE. DESPITE THIS, IT HAS
NOT YET BEEN RECOGNIZED AS AN
OFFICIAL HIGH SCHOOL SPORT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA,
DEPRIVING STUDENTS OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
INTERSCHOLASTIC PLAY. IN
RESPONSE, ACR 211 URGES THE
CALIFORNIA INTERSCHOLASTIC
FEDERATION TO TAKE STEPS TOWARD
OFFICIALLY RECOGNIZING CRICKET
IF ONE OF ITS MEMBER SCHOOLS
BRINGS IT BEFORE THEM FOR
APPLICATION AND CONSIDERATION.
IT ALSO EMPHASIZES THAT THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF HIGH SCHOOL
CRICKET SHOULD SUPPORT CONTINUED
CRICKET PLAY AT THE COLLEGIATE
LEVEL. ACR 211 NOT ONLY
CELEBRATES CRICKET'S RICH
HISTORY, BUT IT ENCOURAGES US TO
ENSURE THAT IT HAS AN EVEN
BRIGHTER FUTURE. SENATORS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR. SEEING
NO MIKE. SUP, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO
GILL. AYE ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBURG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ AYE. DALLY.
AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. NGUYEN
AYE. NILO AYE. AKOBO. AYE
PADIHAM. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALL QUIVERS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE
SENATOR. CORTEZ MOVES A CALL.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 345. LAST
ITEM UNDER ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING. CHANGE OF PRESENTER.
HERE SENATOR DURAZO WILL BE
DOING THIS ITEM. SHE IS READY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 227 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALLACE.
RELATIVE TO WOMEN IN ANIMATION.
SENATOR DURAZO, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT ACR 227, WHICH HONORS
AND ACKNOWLEDGES THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF WOMEN IN THE
ANIMATION INDUSTRY AND THE
ORGANIZATION THAT SUPPORTS AND
PROMOTES THEIR WORK, WOMEN IN
ANIMATION, OR WIA. CALIFORNIA IS
THE BIRTHPLACE OF THE MOST
BELOVED ANIMATED ICONS KNOWN
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD AND HOME TO
MANY PROMINENT ANIMATION
STUDIOS. HOWEVER, WHILE MANY OF
THE ICONIC ANIMATED CHARACTERS
WE'VE GROWN UP WATCHING ARE
WOMEN, WOMEN HISTORICALLY HAVE
BEEN UNDERREPRESENTED IN THE
CREATIVE PRODUCTION SPACE. THREE
DECADES AGO, A GROUP OF WOMEN
FRUSTRATED WITH THIS SYSTEMIC
UNDERREPRESENTATION AND MISTAKEN
BELIEFS THAT WOMEN COULD ONLY BE
PAINTERS AND INKERS, FOUND
FOUNDED WIA. WE ESTABLISHED A
GOAL THAT 50% OF ANIMATORS BE
WOMEN BY 2025. TO ACHIEVE THIS,
WIA WORKS WITH ALL LEVELS OF
PROFESSIONALS WITHIN THE GLOBAL
ANIMATION COMMUNITIES TO EMPOWER
AND ADVOCATE FOR PEOPLE OF
UNDERREPRESENTED GENDER
IDENTITIES IN THE ART,
TECHNOLOGY, PRODUCTION AND
BUSINESS OF ANIMATION. HOWEVER,
THE ANIMATION INDUSTRY FACES NEW
CHALLENGES WITH THE EMERGENCE OF
AI TECHNOLOGY AS A KEY PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S CULTURE AND
ECONOMY. THE INDUSTRY MUST
NAVIGATE THE EVOLVING LANDSCAPE
WHERE AI'S RAPID ADVANCEMENT IS
BEGINNING TO INFLUENCE
TRADITIONAL ROLES AND ARTISTIC
PRACTICES. ACR 227 RAISES
AWARENESS AND CALLS FOR THE
PRESERVATION OF THE CREATIVE AND
CULTURAL SIGNIFICANCE OF OUR
ANIMATION INDUSTRY, AND
PARTICULARLY THE IMPORTANT
CONTRIBUTION OF WOMEN IN AN ERA
OF TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCEMENT.
THANK YOU. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON ACR
227. THANK YOU SENATOR. I SEE NO
MIKES UP FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL. ANY
OBJECTION? SEEING NONE. AYES 37
NØ ZERO. RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE CALLS ON
THOSE FIVE RESOLUTIONS. WE WENT
THROUGH. AND WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH FIVE. ITEM 53. WE'RE
OPENING THE CALLS 553 SR 122
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALAN CABALLERO
AYE. DARAZO. AYE MCGUIRE. AYE.
NEWMAN PADILLA AYE. RUBIO AYE.
UMBERG AYES 37. NO. ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION PASSES NOW. MOVING ON
TO ITEM 99. OPEN ON THE ROLL.
CALL FILE NUMBER 99 A JR NINE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN ALVARADO,
GO. CABALLERO Ã DALLY. NO
GROVE. NO JONES. NO MCGUIRE. AYE
NEWMAN. NGUYEN NO. MILO. NO
OKOBO. NO. UMBERG WILK. NO. EYES
28. NOES EIGHT. RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. FILE ITEM 303 IS ON
DECK FOR ACR 182. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN CABALLERO. AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE. NEWMAN HAMBURG. AYES 37.
NO. ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. FILE ITEM 327 IS ON
DECK. H.R. 818. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN CABALLERO. AYE. TERRAZZO
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR NEWMAN.
UMBERG. AYES 35. NO. ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. NOW ON TO
FILE ITEM 335 ACR 211.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN CABALLERO.
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. NEWMAN UMBERG.
AYES 37. NØ ZERO. THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. LAST ITEM TO CALL
THE ROLL ON AGAIN IS FOR ITEM
THREE. 45 ACR 22. WE SHUT THAT
DOWN AND THEN WE ARE GREAT.
MOVING ON TO CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEMS 349 THROUGH 353 AND
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS
354 THROUGH 365. ANY MEMBER WISH
TO PULL AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDARS. GREAT. I SEE NONE.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ ALL
ITEMS. ASSEMBLY BILL 1533 2879.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3017. SENATE BILL
1063 1514 1058 1106, 1352, 1399,
1410 1429, 1476 1512. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 216 217.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE FIRST ITEM. ALLEN
ALVARADO, GIL A ARCHULETA I,
ASHBY I ATKINS. I BECKER I BLAKE
SPEER I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTEZ I DALLEY I DODD I DURAZO
I EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE I HURTADO JONES HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LIMON I MCGUIRE
I MINGYUAN I MIN I NEWMAN.
NGUYEN I MILO I OCHOA. GOOD JOB
I PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO I SKINNER I CUEVAS
I STERN I UMBERG WAHAB I WIENER
I WILK. I AYES 37 NO. ZERO. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
WE'RE GOING TO BE MOVING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. I'D
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR CORTEZ.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, THERE'S A RESOLUTION AT
THE DESK REQUESTING PERMISSION
TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE 61 FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ALLOWING THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO MEET
AND HEAR ASSEMBLY BILL 1038.
THESE REQUESTS HAVE BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
SENATOR JONES, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I ASK FOR A ROLL CALL.
VOTE ON THIS AND NO VOTE. PLEASE
THANK YOU. SENATOR, SENATOR
CORTEZ IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR JONES IS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. READ THE
RESOLUTION. RESOLVE THAT JOINT
RULE 61 BE DISPENSED WITH AS
REQUESTED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO,
GIL. NO. ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS, I BECKER I BLAKE. SPEER
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ
I DALLEY. NØ DODD I DURAZO I
EGGMAN. GLASER I GONZALEZ. GROVE
NO. HURTADO I JONES. NO. LAIRD I
LIMON I MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR. I
MEAN I NEWMAN. NGUYEN NO. NILO.
NO JABO. NO PADILLA I PORTANTINO,
I ROTH I RUBIO I SATO. NO.
SKINNER I SMILED. CUEVAS I STERN
I UMBERG WAHAB, I WEINER I WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN EGGMAN GONZALEZ I EGGMAN I
NEWMAN UMBERG. AYES 28. NOES
ZERO. MOTION CARRIES 28. AYES
28. NO ZERO. AYES 28. NOES NINE.
MOTION CARRIES. MOVING ON TO
COMMITTEE. AMENDMENTS.
ANNOUNCEMENTS WE HAVE ONE
ANNOUNCEMENT. SENATOR CABALLERO.
APPROPRIATIONS WILL MEET IN 2200
AT 1 P.M. GODSPEED. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. RETURNING TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. THIS IS A TIME
TO DO OUR ADJOURN IN MEMORIES.
SENATORS, IF YOU HAVE A
CONVERSATION AND RESPECTFULLY
ASKING THAT YOU TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR, WE
HAVE FIVE AIMS. WE'RE GOING TO
BE STARTING OFF WITH SENATOR
WAHAB. RIGHT THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF FORMER DISTRICT TEN
STATE SENATOR ELLEN CORBETT. SHE
WAS THE SECOND WOMAN IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY TO SERVE AS
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER. SOME OF
YOU HAVE EVEN ACTUALLY SERVED
WITH HER. SENATOR CORBETT
SHATTERED GLASS CEILINGS AND
OPENED SO MANY DOORS FOR OTHER
WOMEN. IN FACT, SHE BROKE UP THE
GOOD OLD BOYS CLUB IN THE BAY
AREA. SHE BEGAN HER POLITICAL
CAREER IN 1990, WHEN SHE WAS
ELECTED TO THE SAN LEANDRO CITY
COUNCIL. IN 1994, SHE BECAME THE
FIRST EVER DIRECTLY ELECTED
WOMAN MAYOR OF SAN LEANDRO. HER
POLITICAL CAREER WOULD GO ON TO
SPAN THREE DECADES. SAN LEANDRO
MAYOR, STATE ASSEMBLY, SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER, PRESIDENT OF
THE EAST BAY REGIONAL PARKS
BOARD OF DIRECTORS. ELLEN
ACTUALLY NEVER STOPPED WORKING
FOR THE PEOPLE. SHE WAS A TRUE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE EAST BAY,
HAVING ATTENDED CHABOT COLLEGE
AND CAL STATE EAST BAY. SHE
VISITED ME IN MY SENATE OFFICE
JUST IN MY FIRST FEW WEEKS ON
THE JOB, AND SHE TOLD ME THAT IT
WAS VERY NOSTALGIC TO ACTUALLY
BE IN THIS BUILDING AGAIN. AND
AT THE TIME, OBVIOUSLY IT WAS
THE SWING SPACE, AND SHE WAS
HERE IN THIS CAPITOL BUILDING.
AND I REMINDED HER THAT NEARLY
TEN YEARS PRIOR, I ACTUALLY
SHADOWED HER WHEN SHE WAS THE
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER. AND SHE
INSISTED THAT I SIT IN HER CHAIR
AND LOOK UP AND SPIN, AND SHE
CHUCKLED, AND SHE SAID THAT,
YEAH, IT WAS A LONG TIME AGO,
BUT 12 YEARS GOES BY REALLY
FAST. SHE GOES IN A BLINK OF AN
EYE, AND SHE ALWAYS TRIED TO
PROVIDE INSIGHT, ANY TYPE OF
SUPPORT AND MUCH MORE. SHE WAS
ALWAYS VERY SUPPORTIVE OF MYSELF
AND MANY OTHER WOMEN WHO
FOLLOWED HER FOOTSTEPS. AND IN
FACT, WHEN WE WOULD HAVE LUNCH
AT HER FAVORITE SPOT, SHE WAS
ALWAYS WILLING TO BE VERY OPEN,
HONEST AND LISTEN AND TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU WANTED TO
ACHIEVE AND HOW YOU WANTED TO
MOVE AND SUPPORT THE COMMUNITY,
AND HOW SHE COULD BE OF HELP TO
WHAT YOUR GOAL IS. AND I REALLY
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT HER
EFFORT AND HER WORK, BECAUSE
EVEN TILL HER LAST BREATH, SHE
WAS SERVING THE BAY AREA, AND
I'M VERY HONORED TO BE ABLE TO
FOLLOW IN HER FOOTSTEPS AND
REPRESENT THE DISTRICT THAT SHE
ONCE REPRESENTED, I DO WANT TO
SAY MAY SHE REST IN PEACE. AND I
THANK YOU ALL. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SENATOR WAHAB, SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU. MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS, I ALSO RISE
TO ADJOURN IN ELLEN'S MEMORY. WE
OVERLAPPED IN OUR SERVICE. I'VE
KNOWN HER FOR YEARS. OBVIOUSLY,
WE WERE IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TOGETHER, SHE WAS MY NEXT DOOR.
WELL, WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY, SHE WAS MY NEXT DOOR
NEIGHBOR, SENATOR. AND,
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH, AS OUR
COLLEAGUE TALKED ABOUT HER CIVIC
LIFE IN SAN LEANDRO, SHE WAS
BORN IN OAKLAND. AND OAKLAND
ALWAYS HELD A VERY SPECIAL PLACE
TO HER, AND SHE ALWAYS WAS PROUD
THAT THERE WAS A PIECE OF
OAKLAND IN HER DISTRICT. HER
POLITICAL INSTINCTS WERE HONED
EARLY IN LIFE BY HER FATHER. HER
FATHER WAS AN ATTORNEY. HE WAS
ACTIVE IN DEMOCRATIC PARTY
POLITICS. HE WORKED ON RFK,
RFK'S CAMPAIGN FOR PRESIDENT.
AND HE WOULD TELL A FUNNY STORY,
WHICH, OF COURSE, ELLEN WOULD
TELL. THIS WAS HER FUNNY STORY
ABOUT HER FATHER, THAT WHEN HER
FATHER RAN FOR OAKLAND SCHOOL
BOARD, HE WAS IN A RACE WITH TWO
WOMEN, TWO MEN AND ONE WOMAN.
THE MEN SPLIT THE VOTE AND THE
WOMAN WON. THE WOMAN WHO WON WAS
MARCH FONG WU YU AND ELLEN SAID
HER DAD ALWAYS SAID HE WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR MARCH. FONG YU'S
POLITICAL CAREER. ELLEN, AS OUR
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED IN WINNING
SENATE DISTRICT TEN, WAS DAVID
TO GOLIATH BECAUSE SHE HAD SHE
WAS NO LONGER IN THE ASSEMBLY.
SHE WAS OUT OF OFFICE WHEN SHE
RAN AND SHE DEFEATED TWO SITTING
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS, JOHAN CLAES
AND JOHN DUTRA. HER DISTRICT
STAFF WANTED ME TO CONVEY THAT
SHE WAS ESPECIALLY PROUD OF
KEEPING SAN LEANDRO HOSPITAL
OPEN, KEPT IT FROM CLOSING THAT
HER FIRST JOB WAS TOUR GUIDE
HERE IN THE CAPITOL, AND THAT
SHE WAS VERY PROUD THAT EVEN
WITH HER DAUNTING WORK IN THE
CAPITOL, SHE DROVE HOME FROM
SACRAMENTO EVERY DAY DURING THE
SCHOOL YEAR TO BE WITH HER SON,
RYAN. THE OTHER THING IS, IT'S
NO SURPRISE THAT SHE WENT ON TO
BE ON THE BOARD OF THE EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT, A BOARD
I ALSO SERVED ON BECAUSE WHEN
SHE WAS SENATOR AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, SHE WOULD HOLD
LEGISLATIVE WALKS IN THE PARKS
DISTRICT, SO SHE WOULD TALK TO
HER CONSTITUENTS. SHE WOULD HAVE
A METER THERE AND GO ON WALKS
THROUGH THE PARKS. HER PARK
BOARD MEMBERS WERE VERY, VERY
PROUD OF HER, LOVED WORKING WITH
HER. THEY, THEY TOLD ME TO MAKE
SURE TO CONVEY THAT HER DEEPEST
CONCERN WAS TO ENSURE THAT THERE
WAS ACCESS FOR ALL OF OUR
RESIDENTS TO THOSE PARKS. AND
SHE MADE SURE THAT THE PARK
DISTRICT COLLECTED DATA TO MAKE
SURE WHO IS TO IDENTIFY WHO IS
BEING LEFT OUT AND WHY. SO THEY
COULD DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT. AND
AS A MASTER GARDENER, SHE
HERSELF WAS A HUGE ADVOCATE FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT, LOVED THE PARK
DISTRICT AND SHE WILL BE GREATLY
MISSED. SENATOR LAIRD, YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I TOO RISE IN THE
MEMORY OF ELLEN CORBETT. WE MET
WHEN WE BOTH SERVED IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. BUT WHEN I WAS
ELECTED TO THE ASSEMBLY IN 2002,
THERE WAS THIS UNIQUE FACT. AND
THAT WAS IN THE CLASS OF 25
DEMOCRATS ELECTED THAT YEAR.
THERE WAS NOT A SINGLE ATTORNEY.
AS A RESULT, THREE OF US THAT
WERE NOT ATTORNEYS WERE
APPOINTED TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WAS ELLEN
CORBETT. AND SHE TOOK US ALL IN.
WE ALL HAD MAJOR TASKS. SHE
MENTORED US. SHE MADE SURE WE
FELT PART OF THE FULL FAMILY.
AND WHEN THERE WERE VERY
CONTENTIOUS ISSUES, IT HELPED
THAT WE WERE REALLY STANDING
SIDE BY SIDE, ADDITIONALLY, SHE
REPRESENTED MY MOTHER WHEN SHE
WAS IN THE SENATE, AND SHE WOULD
ALWAYS MAKE A POINT WHEN SHE
WENT TO THE SENIOR CENTER IN
PLEASANTON OF SEEKING OUT MY
MOTHER AND CALLING HER BY NAME
AND SAYING HI, WHICH I ALWAYS
APPRECIATED. AND SHE TOOK ON IN
2006, THIS MAJOR BILL TO DEAL
WITH THE ABILITY OF CONSUMERS TO
GET MONEY BACK WITH LEFTOVER
MONEY BELOW A CERTAIN LEVEL ON
GIFT CARDS. I AM THIS YEAR
UPDATING THAT BILL TO TRY TO GET
IT TO WHERE INFLATION WOULD BE,
BUT I WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO DO IT
IF SHE DIDN'T FIGHT A REALLY
PITCHED BATTLE IN 2006, AGAINST
ALL ODDS TO ENACT THAT BILL,
BECAUSE SHE KNEW THAT THAT WAS A
RIGHT CONSUMERS SHOULD HAVE,
THAT THERE'S $20 BILLION OF
UNUSED GIFT CARDS IN A WAY THAT
IF THERE'S A SMALL AMOUNT LEFT,
CONSUMERS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
ACCESS IT. AND EVEN THOUGH IT
WAS THANKLESS, SHE TOOK ON THAT
TASK UNTIL SHE LANDED IT ON THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK. AND IT WAS
SIGNED. SHE WAS A LONGTIME
FRIEND. SHE WAS A GREAT
COLLEAGUE. SHE WAS A TRUE PUBLIC
SERVANT. SHE WAS A GLASS CEILING
BREAKER. AND WE WILL TRULY MISS
HER. THANK YOU. SENATOR WAHAB.
PLEASE BRING THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S NAME FORWARD SO THAT
SHE MAY BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED
IN THE JOURNAL. OUR NEXT ITEM IS
GOING TO BE LED BY OUR MAJORITY
LEADER AND SENATOR DURAZZO.
MAJORITY LEADER. THANK YOU,
MADAM SENATOR. YEAH, I SIT BY
THE MAJORITY LEADER AND SENATOR
DURAZZO. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. IT IS WITH MUCH
SADNESS THAT I RISE AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE LATINO CAUCUS, AS
WELL, TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF RICHARD J. ALATORRE WHO
PASSED AWAY THIS WEEK AT THE AGE
OF 81, OFTEN REFERRED TO AS THE
GODFATHER OF LATINO POLITICS IN
CALIFORNIA, RICHARD LEFT A
LASTING LEGACY OF LATINO
EMPOWERMENT THROUGH HISTORIC
LEGISLATION, COMMUNITY
INVESTMENTS, AND INCREASED
REPRESENTATION. HE WAS THE SON
OF A MEXICAN-AMERICAN MOTHER AND
MEXICAN IMMIGRANT FATHER.
RICHARD GREW UP ON THE EAST SIDE
OF LOS ANGELES. HE ATTENDED CAL
STATE LA AND EARNED A MASTER'S
DEGREE FROM USC. SOON AFTER, THE
CHICANO MORATORIUM. IN 1970, HE
MADE HIS FIRST RUN FOR OFFICE,
NARROWLY LOSING A SEAT FOR THE
ASSEMBLY, BUT HE WON THAT SEAT
DURING THE NEXT CYCLE AND SERVED
FROM 1973 TO 1985. WHILE THERE,
HE AUTHORED LANDMARK LEGISLATION
ESTABLISHING BILINGUAL EDUCATION
AND THE AGRICULTURE,
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
ACT. HE CO-FOUNDED THE CHICANO
CAUCUS, WHICH LATER BECAME, AS
WE KNOW NOW, THE LATINO CAUCUS,
AND CHAIRED THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE, WHERE HE
USED THE REDISTRICTING PROCESS
TO EXPAND ELECTORAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LATINOS AND
ANY AND MANY OTHER MINORITY
CANDIDATES. HIS EFFORTS ALSO
OPENED THE DOOR FOR NEW
GENERATIONS AND CANDIDATES THAT
BEGAN TO DIVERSIFY THE
LEGISLATURE AND EXPAND LATINO
AND LATINO REPRESENTATION. HE
GAINED A REPUTATION AS A BLUNT
AND EFFECTIVE DEALMAKER,
PASSIONATE ADVOCATE FOR THE
UNDERSERVED AND UNDERCOUNTED,
AND A MENTOR TO MANY GROWING AND
ASPIRING POLITICIANS IN LOS
ANGELES. IN 1985, HE HANDILY WON
A SEAT ON THE LOS ANGELES CITY
COUNCIL. THE FIRST LATINO TO WIN
A SEAT ON THE COUNCIL. IN OVER
20 YEARS. AS EDWARD ROYBAL, THE
FIRST LATINO ELECTED, LEFT IN
1962, AND WHILE ON THE COUNCIL,
RICHARD GOT TO WORK AGAIN,
EXPANDING MINORITY
REPRESENTATION THROUGH THE
REDISTRICTING PROCESS. THIS
HELPED USHER IN A NEW GENERATION
OF POLITICIANS, INCLUDING GLORIA
MOLINA. OVER HIS 14 YEARS ON THE
COUNCIL, HE FOUGHT FOR GREATER
INVESTMENTS IN THE MOST
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES ON THE
EAST SIDE OF LOS ANGELES AND THE
GROWTH OF THE EAST SIDE.
POLITICAL MACHINE. RICHARD'S
KEEN POLITICAL ACUMEN AND
STRATEGIC VISION HELPED CHANGE
CALIFORNIA'S POLITICAL LANDSCAPE
FOR THE BETTER. HE WILL FOREVER
BE REMEMBERED AS ONE OF THE KEY
ARCHITECTS OF LATINO EMPOWERMENT
IN OUR STATE. FOR AN AMAZING
ACCOUNT OF HIS LIFE'S WORK, I
RECOMMEND READING RICHARD'S BOOK
CHANGE FROM THE INSIDE MY LIFE.
THE CHICANO MOVEMENT AND THE
STORY OF AN ERA. HE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS WIFE, ANGIE, DAUGHTER
MELINDA. TWO SONS, DEREK AND
DARYL, AND GRANDDAUGHTERS
GABRIELLA, MARIELLA, DANIELA AND
CASEY. AND THEY ARE ALL IN OUR
THOUGHTS AS WE GRIEVE RICHARD'S
PASSING AND HONOR HIS LIFE'S
WORK. I THANK YOU. SENATOR
DURAZO THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, AND THANK YOU FROM LONG BEACH, RICHARD
WAS A CHAMPION CHAMPION FOR OUR
FOR OUR COMMUNITY. HE WAS A
CHAMPION BECAUSE HE FOUGHT FOR
REPRESENTATION BY ENGAGING AND
TRAILBLAZING ON REAPPORTIONMENT,
HE INCLUDED THE COUNT OF
NONCITIZENS IN THE CENSUS BUREAU
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR WHOLE
COMMUNITY WAS COUNTED, AS WAS
SAID, HE WAS AUTHOR OF THE
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
BOARD. WE STILL ARE THE ONLY
STATE IN THE UNITED STATES THAT
RECOGNIZES COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
FOR FARMWORKERS. HE WAS THE
SECOND LATINO TO SERVE IN LA
CITY COUNCIL. AND TO ME, HE WAS
A PERSONAL MENTOR WHEN I BECAME
ACTIVE. AND ONE THE PRESIDENT AS
PRESIDENT OF MY LOCAL UNION
HOTEL AND RESTAURANT WORKERS,
POOR WORKING PEOPLE. WE WANTED
TO MAKE CHANGE IN THE CITY AND
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES. AND
HE STOOD UP AND SAID, I WILL
HELP. BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, HE
WOULD TELL THROUGH STORIES. HE
WOULD TEACH ME WHAT WAS THE
BETTER WAY OF DOING THINGS
WITHOUT YOU KNOW, REALLY
PREACHING AT ME. AND THAT'S WHAT
I LOVED THE MOST ABOUT HIM. HE
REALLY HE WAS INCREDIBLY SMART.
HE WAS VERY SIMPLE ABOUT GETTING
THINGS DONE, HE WAS A GOOD
FRIEND OF MY LATE HUSBAND,
MIGUEL, BECAUSE OF THE FARM
WORKER MOVEMENT, AND PASSED ON
THAT FRIENDSHIP TO ME. AND I'M
VERY, VERY GRATEFUL HE HAD AN
EXTRAORDINARY COMMITMENT TO
JUSTICE, ESPECIALLY TO WORKING
PEOPLE. SO I WOULD SAY THAT
LATINO LAWMAKERS HAVE A GREAT
DEBT TO RICHARD ALATORRE FOR HIS
LANDMARK REDISTRICTING PLAN IN
1981. FARM WORKERS OWE A GREAT
DEBT TO RICHARD ALATORRE BECAUSE
CESAR CHAVEZ SAID THE HISTORIC
FARMWORKER LAW WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN DONE WITHOUT HIM. LATINOS
AND OTHER PEOPLE OF COLOR IN THE
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT,
CIVIL SERVICE Ó RICHARD
ALATORRE, FOR HIS PRECEDENT
SETTING BILINGUAL SERVICES ACT,
THAT HE GOT RONALD REAGAN TO
SIGN IN 1973. THESE ARE ONLY A
FEW EXAMPLES OF ONE OF THE MOST
CONSEQUENTIAL POLITICAL LEADERS
OF OUR TIME. I SEND OUR LOVE AND
CONDOLENCES TO HIS WIFE ANGIE,
HIS DAUGHTER MELINDA, SONS
DERRICK, DARYL AND THE REST OF
THE FAMILY. REST IN POWER.
BROTHER HERMANO RICHARD Ã LÀ TO
Â SI SE PUEDE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SENATOR RUBIO, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I ALSO WANT TO ADD MY
VOICE AND EXPRESS MY DEEP
SADNESS AT THE LOSS OF MR.
ALATORRE, WHO WAS ALSO A
PERSONAL FRIEND OF MINE, AS HE
WAS TO SO MANY IN OUR COMMUNITY.
HE DEFINITELY SET THE BAR HIGH
AS IT PERTAINS TO HIS
LEADERSHIP. AND HE MADE A
TREMENDOUS GAINS IN THE LATINO
COMMUNITY IN THE AREAS OF
EDUCATION. AS I ALREADY
EXPRESSED IN AGRICULTURE, FARM
WORKERS. AND REALLY, I LOOKED UP
TO HIM AND I'M SO INCREDIBLY SAD
TO SEE THAT HE WILL NO LONGER BE
SOMEONE THAT I HAVE AROUND TO,
TO JUST CALL AND TALK TO. BUT I
DO WANT TO OFFER MY CONDOLENCES
TO ANGIE, HIS WIFE MELINDA, WHO
IS A ALSO A PERSONAL FRIEND, AND
DARYL, HIS SON, WHO I KNOW VERY
WELL AS WELL. AND WE'RE ALL
GOING TO MISS HIM. AND WE WANT
TO JUST SAY THANK YOU ON BEHALF
OF ALL LATINOS WHO NEVER SAW
THEMSELVES IN OFFICE, BECAUSE WE
OFTEN DIDN'T SEE PEOPLE LIKE US
IN THESE POSITIONS, WE WANT TO
THANK HIM FOR THE POSITIVE MARK
HE LEFT AND HOW MUCH HE
ENCOURAGED THE NEW GENERATION TO
STEP UP AND WANT TO LEAD. SO
THANK YOU TO HIM AND CONDOLENCES
TO HIS FAMILY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. MAJORITY LEADER,
PLEASE BRING THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S NAME FORWARD SO
THAT HE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED IN THE JOURNAL. UP
NEXT, WE HAVE SENATOR HURTADO.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
ALDO JAVIER GARCIA, A REMARKABLE
YOUNG MAN DEDICATED TO PUBLIC
SERVICE AND A REMARKABLE MEMBER
OF OUR LEGISLATIVE FAMILY. AT
JUST 25 YEARS OLD, ALDO'S
JOURNEY WAS TRAGICALLY CUT
SHORT. YET HIS CONTRIBUTIONS TO
OUR COMMUNITY WILL HAVE A
LASTING IMPACT. ALDO WAS NOT
ONLY A CONSTITUENT FROM MY
DISTRICT, BUT HE WAS ALSO A
FREQUENT VISITOR TO MY OFFICE.
HE WOULD ALWAYS ASK MY TEAM, SO
WHAT ARE YOU GUYS DOING FOR THE
CENTRAL VALLEY? THIS QUESTION
WAS MORE THAN JUST A
CONVERSATION STARTER. IT WAS A
REFLECTION OF ALDO'S DEEP
COMMITMENT TO THE REGION THAT
RAISED HIM. ALDO WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN CORCORAN, CALIFORNIA,
A PLACE WHERE THE LAND AND WATER
ARE INTERTWINED WITH THE LIVES
OF ITS PEOPLE. AS A SON OF FARM
WORKERS, ALDO UNDERSTOOD THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF WATER NOT JUST
AS A RESOURCE, BUT AS A LIFELINE
FOR HIS COMMUNITY AND COUNTLESS
OTHERS ACROSS THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
FROM A YOUNG AGE, ALDO WAS
DRIVEN BY A DESIRE TO GIVE BACK
TO THE COMMUNITY THAT HELPED
SHAPED HIM. HIS JOURNEY TOOK HIM
TO UC BERKELEY, WHERE HE EARNED
A BACHELOR'S OF ARTS IN
POLITICAL SCIENCE AT BERKELEY,
ALDO WAS MORE THAN JUST A
STUDENT. HE WAS A LEADER, A
MENTOR, AND A VOICE FOR THOSE
WHO OFTEN GO UNHEARD. HE WAS
PARTICULARLY PASSIONATE ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND THE
INTERSECTION OF WATER POLICY AND
COMMUNITY WELL-BEING. HE KNEW
THAT ACCESS TO CLEAN, SAFE AND
RELIABLE WATER WAS NOT JUST AN
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE, BUT A
MATTER OF SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
JUSTICE. AFTER GRADUATING FROM
BERKELEY, ALDO WAS SELECTED AS
AN ASSEMBLY FELLOW, WHERE HE
STOOD OUT AMONG HIS PEERS FOR
HIS DEDICATION TO PUBLIC
SERVICE. HE SERVED AS A FELLOW
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORI WILSON.
ALDO QUICKLY BECAME KNOWN FOR
HIS EXPERTISE IN WATER ISSUES,
HIS DEDICATION TO THE PEOPLE OF
THE CENTRAL VALLEY, AND HIS
COMMITMENT TO CRAFTING POLICIES
THAT WOULD MAKE A TANGIBLE
DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES OF
OTHERS. HE CONTINUED HIS WORK AS
A LEGISLATIVE STAFFER FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO,
WHO ALLOWED HIM TO BRING HIS
PASSION AND ADVOCACY FOR THE
CENTRAL VALLEY TO OTHER REGIONS
OF CALIFORNIA. BUT BEYOND HIS
PROFESSIONAL ACHIEVEMENTS, ALDO
WAS A SON. HE WAS A BROTHER, A
FRIEND, AND A LIGHT IN THE LIVES
OF THOSE WHO KNEW HIM. HE WAS
THE KIND OF PERSON WHO MADE
EVERYONE AROUND HIM FEEL VALUED,
WHO COULD FIND THE GOOD IN ANY
SITUATION, AND WHO NEVER LOST
SIGHT OF THE BIGGER PICTURE. HIS
LAUGHTER, HIS KINDNESS, AND HIS
UNWAVERING OPTIMISM WERE A
SOURCE OF STRENGTH FOR ALL WHO
KNEW HIM. AS WE REMEMBER, ALDO
TODAY, WE ALSO HONOR THE DREAMS
HE HELD, THE LIVES HE TOUCHED,
AND THE LEGACY HE LEAVES BEHIND
HIS STORY IS A REMINDER OF THE
INCREDIBLE POTENTIAL THAT EXISTS
WITHIN EACH OF US. THE POTENTIAL
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE TO UPLIFT
OTHERS, AND TO LEAVE THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE THAN WE FOUND IT.
ALDO'S LOSS IS A PROFOUND ONE,
NOT JUST FOR HIS FAMILY AND
FRIENDS, BUT FOR ALL OF US WHO
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING
ALONGSIDE HIM. YET, EVEN IN OUR
GRIEF, WE FIND SOLACE IN THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT HIS SPIRIT LIVES
ON IN THE WORK THAT WE DO IN THE
LIVES WE TOUCH AND IN THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE. IN HONOR
OF ALDO JAVIER GARCIA, LET US
COMMIT OURSELVES TO CONTINUING
THE WORK HE STARTED. TO FIGHTING
FOR JUSTICE. TO SERVING WITH
INTEGRITY, AND TO NEVER LOSING
SIGHT OF THE POWER OF COMMUNITY.
ALDO, YOU WILL BE DEEPLY MISSED,
BUT YOUR LEGACY WILL LIVE ON IN
THE HEARTS AND MINDS OF ALL WHO
KNEW YOU. REST IN POWER, ALDO.
MAY YOUR MEMORY BE A BLESSING
AND A SOURCE OF INSPIRATION TO
US ALL. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
SENATOR. CONDOLENCES FROM THE
SENATE TO THE FAMILY OF ALDO
THAT IS HERE BEHIND US. AND ALSO
IN THE GALLERY. SENATOR, PLEASE
BRING THE YOUNG WARRIORS NAME
FORWARD SO THAT HE MAY FOREVER
BE MEMORIALIZED IN OUR JOURNAL.
SENATOR SKINNER, YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MEMBERS, I ASK YOU
TO JOIN ME IN ADJOURNING IN THE
MEMORY OF MY BROTHER, ROBERT
SKINNER, WHO DIED IN EARLY JULY.
ROB WAS NUMBER SEVEN OF NINE. HE
WAS NOT MY YOUNGEST BABY
BROTHER, BUT HE WAS STILL THE
LITTLE BROTHER THAT I TOOK CARE
OF AS A LITTLE KID. AND THEN OFF
AND ON AGAIN THROUGH THE YEARS,
HE WAS BEAUTIFUL, BLOND, CURLY
HAIR, BLUE EYES, CHUBBY CHEEKS,
AND IN HIS TEENAGE YEARS AND
MOST OF HIS ADULTHOOD, HE WAS
STRIKINGLY HANDSOME, LEAN,
MUSCULAR. AND IF I WERE MY
SISTERS, ANY OF US, WHEREVER WE
WERE WITH HIM AT HOME DEPOT, AT
A HARDWARE STORE, AT THE GROCERY
STORE, EVERY WOMAN, NO MATTER
WHAT AGE, COULDN'T TAKE THEIR
EYES OFF OF HIM. HE WAS A HEAD
TURNER, AND HE MADE HIMSELF
KNOWN WITH A BOOMING VOICE AND A
BIG PRESENCE. IN HIGH SCHOOL, HE
WAS A STAR FOOTBALL PLAYER, AND
BEING THAT STAR, HE HAD A LOT OF
INJURIES. AND THE RESULT OF
THOSE INJURIES IS HE COULDN'T
PLAY THROUGH COLLEGE, WHICH
REALLY WAS SOMETHING HE
REGRETTED GREATLY. HE
PASSIONATELY LOVED SPORTS,
FOOTBALL AND BASEBALL IN
PARTICULAR, AND UNLIKE ME, WHO
WAS A NATIVE OF SAN FRANCISCO,
HE WAS BORN IN LA AREA. HIS TEAM
WAS THE DODGERS, ANYWAY, HE ALSO
LOVED THE RAIDERS AND NOTRE
DAME. HE HAD ENCYCLOPEDIC
KNOWLEDGE OF MOVIES. ASK HIM
ANYTHING. HE SAU KNEW EVERY
LINE. HE LOVED ROCK N ROLL,
ESPECIALLY THE WHO, THE STONES
AND PINK FLOYD. FOR MOST OF HIS
WORK LIFE, HE WAS A
SELF-EMPLOYED CONTRACTOR. BUT
MORE THAN THAT, HE WAS A SKILLED
BUILDER. HE BUILT CUSTOM
DESIGNED HOUSES AND REMODELS
WITH CABINETRY, TILING AND MORE
THAT HE DESIGNED AND BUILT WITH
HIS OWN HANDS. BUT HIS PROUDEST
ACCOMPLISHMENT WAS HIS SON,
KEVIN. HE WAS A LOVING FATHER,
AND HE MADE SURE TO BE IN TOUCH
WITH KEVIN AT LEAST WEEKLY.
KEVIN LIVES IN CHICAGO, AND
KEVIN RECENTLY BECAME ENGAGED
AND IT FURTHER INCREASED MY
BROTHER'S PRIDE FOR KEVIN. BUT
MY BROTHER ROB, LIKE SO MANY
PEOPLE THAT WE LOVE OR WHO WE
KNOW OR WHO ARE IN OUR FAMILY OR
OUR CONSTITUENTS. HE HAD A LOT
OF STRUGGLES, ADDICTION, MENTAL
HEALTH, LIKELY BIPOLAR DISORDER,
UNFORTUNATELY, A NUMBER OF
ADDICTIONS, SOME HE WAS ABLE TO
TACKLE, OTHER TIMES THEY TACKLED
HIM. WHILE ROB WAS NEVER
INCARCERATED, HE HAD A LONG RAP
SHEET, HE TOLD ME, AND I
CERTAINLY OBSERVED THAT HE
BELIEVED THAT HE GOT THE BENEFIT
OF THE DOUBT BECAUSE HE WAS
WHITE WITH THE EXTRA BONUS OF
BEING BLOND AND BLUE EYED. ROB
IS ONE OF THE REASONS THAT SO
MUCH OF MY WORK HAS BEEN FOCUSED
ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM AND
ANTI-POVERTY, AND ESPECIALLY IN
THE AREA OF HOUSING, BECAUSE IN
THE LAST 12 OR 15 YEARS, HE
COULDN'T EVEN AFFORD TO KEEP A
ROOF OVER HIS HEAD. FOR MANY
YEARS HE LIVED IN MY PROPERTY,
OR HE LIVED WITH ANOTHER SISTER,
OR HE LIVED IN DIFFERENT SPOTS,
COUCH SURFED AND SUCH. THANK
GOD, NEVER FULLY ON THE STREET.
BUT WHENEVER I OR OTHERS
REALIZED THAT HE WAS LIVING IN
HIS CAR, WE MADE SURE TO GET HIM
OUT OF THERE. BUT OUR SAFETY NET
IS NOT ENOUGH TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE LIKE HIM ARE NOT EITHER
IN THE CAR OR THE TENT. HIS
STRUGGLES COULD OFTEN GET THE
BEST OF HIM, AND IT MADE IT
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT. AS I
MENTIONED, FOR HIM TO KEEP A JOB
OR SECURE NEW ONES. HE HAD MANY
CAPABILITIES AND SO MUCH TO
GIVE, BUT HE COULDN'T ALWAYS
FUNCTION THE WAY THAT WE EXPECT.
PEOPLE TO. HE NEVER GAVE UP. HE
ALWAYS KEPT TRYING. HE, IN FACT,
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS WAS
DILIGENTLY APPLYING TO ALL OF
THE HOUSING LISTS. AND I THINK I
MENTIONED THAT ON THE FLOOR
BEFORE HE FINALLY GOT IN TO A
SUBSIDIZED UNIT THAT HE COULD
AFFORD AND HAD MOVED INTO A
STUDIO JUST IN JUNE FOR THE LAST
FEW YEARS, HE WAS A VOLUNTEER
FOOTBALL COACH AT ALAMEDA HIGH
SCHOOL, VOLUNTEERING DURING A
TIME WHEN HE COULDN'T EVEN
AFFORD GAS SO HE'D RIDE HIS BIKE
THERE MILES. AND BEING WITH
THOSE KIDS, THOUGH, GAVE HIM JOY
AND PURPOSE. PURPOSE AND JOY
THAT HE SO NEEDED IN THE LAST
FOUR YEARS, WHILE HE WAS
STRUGGLING MOST WITH HIS
ADDICTIONS, HIS MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES, AND HIS POVERTY. DESPITE
HIS CHALLENGES, MY BROTHER
BROUGHT VALUE TO THIS WORLD AND
TO MANY PEOPLE'S LIVES. HE GAVE
MUCH. I DEEPLY LOVED HIM. I
STILL CAN'T BELIEVE I WILL NEVER
SEE HIM AGAIN. AT ONLY 62, ROB
WAS TAKEN TOO EARLY. MAY HE REST
IN PEACE AND MAY WE ALL KNOW AND
TRUST THAT EVERY PERSON HAS
VALUE AND MUCH TO GIVE. WE IN
THE LEGISLATURE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE THAT THE
POLICIES THAT WE ADOPT GIVE
EVERY PERSON THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DEMONSTRATE THEIR VALUE AND TO
BE RECOGNIZED FOR WHAT THEY CAN
GIVE US. WE NEED TO COMMIT
OURSELVES TO DO THAT. THANK YOU
FOR ADJOURNING AND MY BROTHER'S
MEMORY. SENATOR ATKINS, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO SHARE IN
THE COMMENTS OF OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM BERKELEY, MOSTLY BECAUSE
MANY OF US HAVE LIVED THIS
EXPERIENCE WITH HER, AND WE HAVE
LEARNED FROM HER. SHE SAID. A
LOT OF WHAT I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT, WHICH IS IN HER EARLY
YEARS, SHE REALLY WAS THE MOTHER
TO HER BROTHERS AND SISTERS, AND
SHE TOOK IT SERIOUSLY EVEN TO
THIS DAY. AND IN TERMS OF THE
SUPPORT AND LOVE THAT SHE GAVE
HER BROTHER, ROB, I JUST WANT TO
SAY WE COMMEND YOU MUCH OF THE
POLICY WORK, AS YOU MENTIONED,
YOU HAVE DONE HAS BEEN ON BEHALF
OF LIVED EXPERIENCES OF MANY IN
THE COMMUNITY. BUT YOUR FAMILY
AND WE HAVE BENEFITED FROM THAT.
IT'S RIGHT THAT WE SHARE AND
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY, BECAUSE
EACH OF US, MANY OF US, YOUR
COLLEAGUES, HAVE BEEN WITH YOU
EACH STEP OF THE WAY, SOME OF US
FOR THE LAST 14 YEARS. AND SO TO
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY ON
BEHALF OF OUR COLLEAGUES, WE
JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT WE
SUPPORT YOU. WE REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE HUMANENESS FROM
WHICH YOU HAVE BROUGHT YOUR
POLICY WORK TO LIGHT, AND THE
STORIES THAT YOU HAVE SHARED AND
WE ARE GRATEFUL, AND WE KNOW
THAT WE HAVE BENEFITED FROM
THIS. AND WE WANT TO JOIN YOU IN
MEMORY OF AN INCREDIBLE
INDIVIDUAL WHO GAVE MUCH TO THIS
WORLD. AND YOU HELPED US
RECOGNIZE THAT VERY FACT AND THE
COMPLEXITY OF ALL OF THESE
ISSUES. YOU HAVE TO LOOK THROUGH
AND FIND WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT.
AND YOU'VE ALLOWED US TO DO
THAT. AND WE THANK YOU FOR
MAKING ROB PART OF OUR LIVES AS
WELL. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. SENATOR SKINNER, YOUR
SENATE FAMILY WRAPS YOU UP IN
LOVE AND SUPPORT DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME. YOUR BROTHER
WILL BE FOREVER MEMORIALIZED IN
THE SENATE JOURNAL. SENATOR
BLAKE SPEAR, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU. I'M MOVED BY THE
PREVIOUS ADJOURN IN MEMORY,
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE TODAY IN HONOR OF THE LIFE
AND MEMORY OF 19 YEAR OLD NICOLE
BARTASH. HER FATHER IS PART OF
THE CITY STAFF IN ANAHEIM. AND
SENATOR UMBERG WISHED THAT HE
COULD BE HERE TODAY TO
MEMORIALIZE NICOLE. TRAGICALLY,
AFTER BATTLING A GENETIC
DISORDER, FANCONI ANEMIA, NICOLE
PASSED AWAY ON JUNE 7TH, 2024,
AT AGE 19. SHE GREW UP IN
ANAHEIM, CALIFORNIA, AND
ATTENDED NOVA ACADEMY CHARTER
HIGH SCHOOL IN SANTA ANA. SHE
GRADUATED LAST YEAR, JUNE 2023.
AS A STUDENT ON THE HONOR ROLL,
SHE ACHIEVED THIS RECOGNITION BY
MAINTAINING HER NAME ON THE
HONOR ROLL FOR ALL FOUR YEARS OF
HIGH SCHOOL. IN ADDITION, SHE
GRADUATED WITH A COMMUNITY
SERVICE RECOGNITION FOR
RECORDING OVER 120 HOURS OF EXTENSIVE
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND MEDICAL NOT
GIVE HER THE CHANCE TO ENROLL IN
COLLEGE. SHE LOVED RIDING
HORSES, LISTENING TO K-POP, AND
TAKING CARE OF HER DOG, LUNA. IN
HER SHORT TIME, HER SMALL BUT
MIGHTY PERSONALITY TOUCHED MANY
LIVES. NICOLE IS SURVIVED BY HER
PARENTS, DAVID AND NAM, AND HER
YOUNGER BROTHERS, JOSEPH AND
MATTHEW. SENATORS, I ASK THAT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY. THANK YOU
SENATOR. HER YOUNG LIFE WILL BE
FOREVER EMBEDDED IN THE SENATE
JOURNAL IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS. SENATOR MCGUIRE, THE
DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU. SO
MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS
WE ARE LOOKING TO NEXT WEEK. I
WANT TO REMIND MEMBERS, AS I
KNOW WE DON'T NEED ANY REMINDER
THAT WE WILL BE LIVING IN THESE
CHAMBERS OVER THE NEXT TWO
WEEKS. WE'LL BE WORKING. AS WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER, TO ABOUT 6:00
EACH NIGHT NEXT WEEK, AND THEN
OUR FINAL WEEK OF SESSION WILL
BE WORKING ALL HOURS OF THE
MORNING, NOON AND NIGHT, AND
WANT TO REMIND MEMBERS THAT
WE'LL BE LOOKING AT AUGUST 31ST,
WHICH IS A SATURDAY, AS A
SESSION DAY AS WELL. WITH THAT
AND WITH THIS EMOTIONAL
ADJOURNMENT, SENATOR SKINNER, WE
HOPE YOU ARE ABLE TO SPEND TIME
WITH YOUR FRIENDS AND FAMILY
THIS WEEKEND AND REST UP AS WE
HAVE A BUSY TWO WEEKS. THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY, AUGUST 19TH AT 2 P.M.
ENJOY YOUR WEEKEND OF FREEDOM!
STRAP IN FOR NEXT WEEK. THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
ALL LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS HAS
BEEN RECEIVED AT THE DESK. WE
WILL RECONVENE MONDAY, AUGUST
19TH AT 2 P.M.